welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to the
pregame
[Applause]
I think they do do it for the men but
it's like sexual tension it's not
relationship attention so you can kind
of do a cheat code you can go get a BBL
get a nice body and you do get more
attention from them than if you're flat
right but here's the thing though no no
but but listen though if it goes so
deeper though because I know what you're
talking about and she has a great body
yeah so you got to think about how far
down deep that she is within watching
the Instagram models within watching The
Cosmopolitan magazines
doesn't look good to a man but you think
that men have higher standards for women
not that the men have the higher
standards they have to live up to just
to clarify I think men have highest end
is for women for women so like the women
have higher beauty standards to me yes
and that's what's making women feel like
they need to comply with these standards
who's pickier men or women men and women
are more complacent than men
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept all them men do you think men are
very like if they're they've got a
certain standard they're more rigid than
women I think men are pickier than women
100 definitely but they will not marry
it they will not settle down with
somebody with a fake or lips the
eyebrows and if they do it ain't gonna
last oh I I done an only fans but it
wasn't like vagina boobs it was lingerie
yeah builds right whatever I'd done it
and when I finished it I felt very
degraded I felt very like why did I
actually do that now I know there's
girls out there who do that they don't
feel that way that is perfectly fine you
do you you feel the way you feel but me
personally like like in the future how
like when I have kids and all in the
future and if my kids found out about
that they'll probably get bullied in
school there are people like oh your mom
doing this your mom doing that and your
man as well he's not going to if you
don't respect yourself and you're
selling your body online I can't speak
for everyone I can just speak for myself
if you're selling your body online like
that there's not there's not a high
respect for yourself
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and as that is the
most important metric that YouTube uses
to push out these streams and as you
guys already know if you have watched
two or more of my lives and you don't
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
a couple announcements before we start
the show
um the first announcement is that we
have a Google form um so if you guys
want to be notified of our next Meetup
that we're going to do in London make
sure you sign up for that also guys we
have four membership tiers I could go
through all of them but the only one
that matters is the fourth tier which
you get a one-on-one call with me once a
month um do you want to know how to run
a live show how to get a million
subscribers in a year I'll tell you on
that call also guys um they banned my
Instagram so go follow my new one just
pearly things one
um they also I've also been kicked off
at Tic Tac five times now I'm so I'm so
salty with that app but I have a new
account I got my first username back so
now I'm back to just pearly things
um I'm almost to a thousand followers or
so go post go follow it and I might post
again
um also guys go subscribe to wife school
um we're getting a new editor this week
so I swear we're gonna have the cooking
ones coming out soon I swear we've done
so many I've been promising you guys
that forever it's coming I swear
um also guys make sure you go subscribe
to just pearly animations
um and how many likes do we need to open
up the chat today blessing one thousand
okay a thousand likes and we will open
up the chat if you want to be a part of
our chat make sure you sign up for our
first membership tier
I feel like I have another announcement
but I can't remember what it was
okay well I'll let you guys know if I
think of it later anyways um today we
have a lovely panel um welcome to the
show guys
um to start what do you guys say your
name your age your relationship status
um and what you do for a living so
starting here and then go around
my name is Christine I'm 22 years old
I'm in a relationship and I'm a sales
executive selling printers to businesses
I'm for real yeah oh girl I did that
God bless what what do you sell
um print services so the printer and the
service that goes with it alright since
I literally used to sell that God bless
them
God bless go ahead go ahead
um I'm Naomi I'm 35 and I do recruitment
for a residential children's home
hi I'm nadashi Hopkins I'm 26. my
relationship status I'm happy
somewhere
um I'm a businesswoman I do acting and
dancing welcome to the show thank you go
ahead um my name's Shea I'm 20. and my
relationship status is single and I'm
just a student right now
yeah it's your boy I'm back
Fresh Prince is on Monday and subscribe
to that channel you know I'm saying
we're coming up we're coming up you know
what I'm saying you know Zane Zane
uh what's the questions again name age
relationship status and what you do for
a living okay Troy Francis uh 47 and
single and I am a dating coach plus uh
content creator plus writer
scanner people
I go by beard gang 28 single members
and as you know I've been connecting bid
since 2019 so if you're busy lacking
just hit me in a DM beard gang members
geez man's got my 20 today so
I know all about them trying to get my
bed nice like beds again
um oh yeah that was my announcement um
to go subscribe to your channel oh yeah
come on but I actually don't even know
how to spell it yeah
[Laughter]
we might we might work on the name I
don't know I don't know um the link to
that blessing can you put it in the
description the link to his channel yeah
you you how many tell them how many
reaction videos you filmed in three days
uh 30.
[Music]
you still had reactions
it reminds me of me when I first started
oh and that's what I would do I just sit
there and just keep keep funning them
out yeah
cranking them out I'm gonna stop into
that diamond that diamond things in my
house you know
um okay so today
um we are talking about a couple that is
in the news all right there's a famous
soccer player
[Music]
who recently was divorced
and he his you know soon ex-wife had a
very big surprise in the divorce playing
the video blessing
um also shout out to chisha said if
we're going to react to his video today
[Music]
my name is said Frank the copy it'll
make you feel better professional
footballer Ashraf akime's wife filed for
divorce and demanded half of his
property we've heard the story before
but this one's a little bit different
she was informed by the court that her
millionaire husband owns
nothing
[Music]
how could that be how could that be she
was shocked I'm sure the whole courtroom
was shocked to find out that her plan to
get half of everything he owns
was immediately disrupted why well
because all his property is registered
under his mother's name wow this is
definitely some bitter coffee for that
ex-wife or soon to be ex-wife she's
drinking black coffee we're drinking uh
some coffee with with a little bit of of
creamer in it today because you know
this is good news
yeah man I got the DMS from you guys a
bunch if you wanted me to talk about
this so it's trending everywhere but
there's more to the store than just this
trending headline we're going to look at
what exactly might be going on in the
background what led to the situation
possibly and also what the people have
to say about everything that's going on
so those of you who may not know Ashraf
hakime is a professional footballer who
plays for ligue one Club Paris Saint
Jermaine and Morocco national team but a
lot of people probably don't know and I
personally didn't know because I just
don't follow soccer that closely about
the story is that on March 3rd
Ashraf had been indicted by Paris Police
over allegations of grape the man was
recently metooed and placed under
judicial supervision on March 3rd last
month now three weeks later on March
27th his wife
filed for divorce or at least you went
online to announce that she was
divorcing and leaving her husband and
they were awaiting divorce proceedings
now two weeks later after that
everything took a shocking turn when
this news was released in court it was
found that the 24 year old famous soccer
player had no assets under his name she
took him to court so that she could take
away his Essence right we're not
surprised
it was reported that all his properties
jury and cars were all under his mom's
name real quick shout out to that Mom
man who came through for her son because
I have never heard of this [__] before
in my life usually especially as young
as this professional athlete is a lot of
professional athletes end up broke
majority of them do
and that's because they don't take the
initiative to protect their wealth
understand money
and how to grow wealth outside of the
sport but just protecting yourself after
divorce is usually very difficult for a
lot of these athletes to do they don't
take it seriously not only were the
properties jewelry and cars underneath
the mom's name but she also received 80
percent of his 15.7 million dollar wage
therefore it meant that Ashraf had no
assets to split with his wife from what
I know and where it stands now she gets
nothing so they do have two children two
sons in specific and a lot of people are
speculating that the reason for her
initiating that divorce
um was based on him inviting some chick
over
while his wife and kids were off on
vacation and then that chick who came
over to his place claiming that he
forced himself on her what do you guys
think of that right curious you know
what you guys think of that as I was
going to check out some of these
comments see what the people have to say
this is an obvious win of course for
eign
as far as his assets go but this post
came from wealth they commented and this
is an Instagram page they commented he
said ma hold the bag coming at 19 000
likes another comment here none other
than Francis inganu uh added and said
that's how you do it five thousand likes
shout out to Francis man another person
here a woman chimed it and says y'all
clapping for him but this is kind of
disturbing okay so she disagrees we have
a woman here who doesn't like what's
going on she goes on to say because
maybe the reason for the divorce is due
to his inability to make moves without
his mom smart for sure but strange
[Music]
what do you guys think of that do you
guys think that's the reason for the
divorce I mean with the data we know now
and these women initiating divorces over
anything
um I think she probably thought of a
reason found it and decided it was worth
initiating for that divorce in her eyes
but let's see what the people have to
say because people responding back to
that chick for example this man who said
doubt it
and another commenter who added
obviously the mother is the only one
that won't leave him and take half of
his money 951 likes another person who
says best comment in response to that
guy I have seen on internet
another man here says how is that
strange in response to that chick
especially in a world we live in and
after seeing so many cases I'll say that
was very smart for him why should your
wife be automatically eligible to get
half your [__] just because you don't
want to be with him no more this turned
into a threat and a lot of people chimed
in this next person said she probably
paid someone to accuse of grape oh [__]
so she can file a divorce and get half
of his money what do you guys think of
that I don't know you know I think
far out speculations but hey who knows
another person here says so for that she
deserves to split half of the man's
wealth
okay and finally another comment here to
end Brad says men okay
so what is you guys reaction to that
story who's right who's wrong was it
smart was it wrong
okay she she's got I could see I could
see you during the reaction on the edge
of your seat God I think he's a smart
guy
because especially with marriages and
when you have a lot of money
people will do anything to get a piece
of your pie and I'm I'm coming from a
place where I've had people take a piece
of my pie like I have been scammed over
10 grand of my money because don't you
get scrammed for scam for ten girls
[Laughter]
um it was uh from a very I'm not going
to say the name of the company
but basically why not beat them up I
know because I don't want to get sued
and then they take more money off of me
no no no no so
um
this company promised my company to
advertise market and promote my business
and obviously this
um
business was a Pakistani and the reason
why they didn't follow with all the
agreements in The Proposal fee at the
end of my performance at Wembley Arena
last year in August they go
the reason why we didn't do all those
things is because you're not Pakistani
so they took my money I did a free
performance in front of 12 500 people
and 10 grand just went woof
so so when it comes to that I think he's
very smart for giving his assets to his
mom so people don't take it because
anyone will take that opportunity just
to take something from me
what do you think
I mean
I feel like
I do think it was a smart move I think
like it was obviously very calculated
however I don't necessarily think that
when you're divorcing someone I don't
think it's scamming to like
take some of their money or whatever
when you divorce someone you think
you're entitled do man's money and
divorce
that he made
um entitled
not necessarily but I think for example
in some situations where you might have
given up your career to raise children
or whatever like you decided to put the
money that you're making on hold to put
effort into growing three out of three
out of four women work so most women
most women work when they have children
three yeah it says three out of four
mothers in the UK work but also it's
head choice to have those children with
him and those children surely are going
to still be looked after by their father
so like financially I'm sure he's his
mother's not going to be allowed bye
couldn't you argue it's an even trade
because she gets time with the kids that
he doesn't get so wouldn't you say
that's an even trade
you don't think time with your kids is
more valuable than that's not what I'm
saying I feel as though if a father
wants to have time with his children I
feel like you know legally he has the
right to fight to have more time with
his children if that's what he knows if
that's what he know but I was saying I
was saying during the marriage you don't
think that's an equal Exchange
so she gets time with the children and
she has to put her career on hold but he
he gets to do the career thing and he
doesn't get the time with his kids so
you don't think that's a fair exchange I
don't think that's an equal exchange I
don't think those two things that equal
like it's a better deal than that that's
not me saying that necessarily working
on your career is better than spending
time with your children but I feel as
though when if you guys are to split up
or have a divorce it does put you at an
advantage if you have spent time
furthering your career and well then
shouldn't you stay
shouldn't you not get divorced then
so you just think that women should put
up with anything and stay in the
relationship there most things yeah I
think pretty much everything yeah can I
can I can I I think yeah I think I think
otherwise stay in a relationship why get
married isn't like what happened to her
better for worse for sickness and health
for richer or for poorer and throws your
vows don't they matter so death do us
part about being cheated on isn't past
all right can I interject though how why
are we assuming that the kids are gonna
go to her why not yeah you are I I
didn't assume anything no but I'm saying
the way how the direction of the
conversation is going it's like we know
that the kids are are going to her like
he's a footballer right trains a couple
hours yeah she was on about whilst he
was while there married not separation
we haven't even got to them no
information no no no we have got to
support no we didn't yeah you could you
could rewound the podcast we actually
did get to that part when we're talking
about afterward when he when he's
leaving after they've left this lady was
talking about whilst they're in the
relationship still is it a fair exchange
but I was saying is Fair exchange that
he she gets to stay at home and the
value that she gets from that and him
working they're still married I
understand that point and after we
talked about leaving and where the
children should go no I said that when
they when they separate he has right
Advantage there we go no but I never
said it wasn't I couldn't she couldn't
she have an advantage to getting
remarried and being a stay-at-home wife
then she has an advantage she has more
wife skills
no
like if you were a stay-at-home wife
then you'd have stay-at-home wife skills
so wouldn't you have an advantage if you
wanted to get remarried but yeah
you've got children now though so you
automatically devalued yeah
you see that's what that's what I'm
trying to say you devalue what do you
mean like how do you know the kids are
going to go to her you're not saying
hold on let me let me let me let me try
and Nuance my point yeah if she has no
kids because the kids are with him then
there's no responsibility two children
so she's still automatically in the eyes
of a man when he's looking at that woman
no he's a woman not devalued because I'm
I'm looking at I have to pay for the
kids if the kids are not at the house
catch up we're talking about something
different wait no Amiri I think she's
saying that she like the mom is less
valuable when she has kids I know I know
what she's saying yeah that's literally
like am I talking like no no Marshall or
something I just didn't understand I'm
saying literally the reason why it's a
problem if a woman has kids is because I
have to look after them but if the kids
are with the man then I don't have to
look after them but she'll still have
them at some point there'll still be
moments where they come over and that
it's like yeah but that's not why men
are like saying to
um to stay away from women with kids is
because I'm gonna have to look after the
kids I'm gonna get a second my children
sad am I then more valuable say that
again if I send my son to his dad am I
now like high Market yeah but then this
could be higher Market yeah because
because like think about it if you're
the dad primary custody you'd only have
the kids what three days but then six
six days a month wouldn't the question
then be like why what's wrong with you
like what why does your why do you not
have 50 share like if that if the
father's willing to do like a big
portion of it why wouldn't it be 50 like
are you asking me also do you think like
Society values women that don't look
after their children no no no I don't
what do you what do you mean say that
again because I mean you guys are saying
that a woman's higher value if the
children sorry sorry sorry you guys are
saying that a woman's higher value if um
her children are with their their dad or
not with them primarily so like do you
guys think that Society
respects women who she was speculating
she was speculating that I think she I
don't think you should turn it
definitively yet she was just sort of
flight to the idea I mean I think in
some ways uh a guy might prefer to meet
a woman who's
less incumbent with children you know
because some guys do have a you know an
issue with she's got three kids he's
like do I want to take that on if she if
they're not around potentially you might
say well maybe that's going to be more
of an attractive proposition but you are
right on the other hand if the other way
of looking at it is well you know she
couldn't look after her kid so if if
he's looking for somebody to produce
more kids with then maybe she's not such
a good bet but I think but just to just
to the point of this guy the footballer
and what he did did he do the right
thing 100 man this has got to be this is
this has got to be the flute I did that
this has got to be the blueprint this is
the smartest thing I've ever heard this
has got to be the blueprint for every
single man now for the for the rest of
Eternity sign all your money over to
your mum that's it that's it guys
wasn't he significantly younger than her
as well even better yeah I also read
that she now on paper is more wealthy
than him so he is entitled to 50 of hers
in the device
she's wealthier than he is so he's
actually entitled to like some of her
money that's what I read today can I get
back to that point like let me land a
little bit because it's not like it's
not that she's more
appealing because she the kids are with
the father it's necessarily my resources
are less wasted I want to say because
okay say for example I get connected to
the kids she she could leave and take
her kids because they're not my kids but
I've invested my time my money into the
kids that we're
um looking after if the kids are not
dead and I don't need to invest no time
into them I'm not spending no money on
them so like I don't see how I'm losing
by being with her do you understand what
I'm trying to say I'm not saying she's
more valuable I'm just saying it's less
money I'm coming out my pocket yeah
hmm
do you have anything let me show you
what do you
think
uh smart but obviously it depends on
your relationship with your mom do I
mean otherwise more footballers would do
it
find really sucks it could be very like
controlling if your money's if you have
to ask to do things online please the
relationship's got to be on a certain
level something is so sus about that
chick going to his house
and then
um
I don't think so necessarily because I
don't think it's like outlandish to for
football yeah
for the fat chick is um
happens all the time to footballers
isn't it it's like so I feel I generally
feel bad for the guy yeah well and the
problem is in in family court you don't
need evidence to accuse a guy of that so
so yeah it's based on a balance of
probabilities not it's not it's based on
a balance of probabilities it's not
based on evidence
so essentially like girls can accuse men
of assault and family court and there's
no consequence for it yeah and and they
can lose the kids like based on this and
they don't even get a judge a jury a
trial yeah okay that's so messed up
um do you guys believe in divorce if so
for what reasons
I love how you're just looking at me and
now I'm ready
I mean I do believe in divorce like I
don't necessarily believe that divorce
is an inherently bad thing and I do
think it's for the the greater good
sometimes okay what how like in what
instances yeah
I mean if you're not
I mean if you're not happy if you're not
being respected I just feel like I'm not
happy I was waiting for the happy don't
you think don't you think happiness
comes and goes hmm
to an extent of course happiness comes
and goes but if you're in a relationship
and that relationship is causing you
unhappiness for the majority of time
that you've been in it then do you think
is it happiness a choice
that's why you can choose to be in the
relationship or not if the
relationship's not making you happy you
choose but do you go to a relationship
to make you happy or should or should
you look for happiness Within
I mean you can do both simultaneously I
don't think that that completely
separate I believe you can be happy in
yourself and at the same time not happy
in the relationship that you're in so
should the marriage vows switch to for
richer for poorer until I'm happy
and sickness and in health and if I'm
not happy
not necessarily but I just I don't
understand why you guys truly believe
that you should stay in a relationship
that's causing your unhappiness because
because I'll tell you why because I
think once you have kids it's not about
you anymore and once you start a family
unit it's not about you you know I
talked to a guy down the street he runs
um a homeless shelter he's been in a
homeless shelter for 40 years working
with the people and I asked him what's
the number one cause of of um
of homelessness like why why does this
happen he tells me single mother homes
so a lot of times like women make
choices for themselves and for their
happiness but there's effects in society
that happen because of the choice they
made where it's like yeah okay you you
might be happy but how is your child
going to feel when he gets to see his
dad six days a month
yeah but how does the child feel when
you're when they're stuck in a home with
two parents that are arguing non-stop
constantly all day I don't think
necessarily that staying in a
relationship just to make the kids Happy
is the best decision for the kids
wouldn't a better solution be figure out
how to get along with your husband
you can do that in separate houses as
long as you co-parent perfectly I think
it could I know it can work because
that's exactly what I do it wouldn't it
be better it would in the same way 100
if if it could have worked then the
ideal would be
what couldn't work explain to me so what
what couldn't work with your you said
you did that so what what couldn't work
serial cheating I'm not gonna put up
with cereal tea and so for me it wasn't
the dynamic
and you were a hundred percent you never
cheated ever 100 percent
and I thought I was going to spend the
rest of my life with him and so before
the relationship you never caught him
cheating you had no inkling we yeah what
do you mean before sorry before the
child sorry oh yeah yeah 100 and when I
fell pregnant with my son it wasn't like
we didn't plan to have
um and
um we were engaged so in my naive young
mind so you were the kid before you got
married yeah I got engaged and I had my
son
um in my mind naively I thought
the fact that he had proposed and we
were having a baby that was him so there
was like a change or a shift somehow
obviously it was incorrect how did you
find out about him cheating
um yeah
it was a relationship that happened so I
don't want to go into details because
obviously it's his business as well as
mine
um but she was crying down the phone to
me so yeah oh she called you yeah how
did you know she was telling the truth
um well he didn't deny it he was stood
in front of him
and so yeah
and I I felt sorry for her because she
didn't know that we were still together
and so
um but I don't we were both really young
like when I look back he we were I was
19 he was 21 when we met we were both in
the military so it wasn't like we were
around each other all the time so the
dynamic was very different than I guess
people that are living in the same house
every day you said you're single now
right do you think you're in a better
situation now
for my son those two together personally
yeah yeah 100 well what is what does
life look like after 55 if you're by
yourself
I'm not going to be by myself by 7 55. I
don't know because I'm not there I don't
know but no but that's what I'm saying a
lot of times like we think we can like
we do better like what if what if you
don't well if I that would that's would
that decision still be the right one in
hindsight
um yeah you'd rather be by yourself well
there's lots of things out there that I
can do to be of service to there's many
places and
um spaces that I can serve without it
being oh I feel like I've given my life
fully because I've got an amazing son we
co-parent amazingly and so they it was a
choice that I made so I have to just
hold that and hold it out
it does but but from what you're saying
it's not an owl well no I mean in
hindsight maybe when I get to 55 but I'm
not there at the moment in this present
time I don't feel like it's an owl but
if I get to 55 and I'm like oh damn it
I'm here with my
I live in Thailand do you do you think
you'd have enough money to save for like
retirement at that age okay you'll be
okay yeah because I I think you need
like what do they say 1.5 million to
serve to retire I don't think I'll
retire at 55. there's 65 even I don't
even think it's 60. my grandma was
working right up until she had her own
little shop yeah but you don't know if
you get sick you don't know if something
will happen I've got insurance for all
of that okay okay you must enjoy fully
insured you mentioned about the ages
though do you think this is part of the
problem because like the way you're
describing it you were like he was 21
you were 19 when you guys got married
because I think I think we weren't
married but when we got together oh you
were married no we got engaged no I
didn't get too large of it oh okay that
that affects it then because like I
think a point Pearl often makes is that
if you look at the marriage vows what
are the marriage vows you know you know
I wouldn't have gotten if I had got
married yeah there would have been no
divorce we would have just been stuck
with each other I guess I guess it was
easier because we hadn't got married yet
but um I think because when my when I
had my son I'd only just had him when I
found out and I was like
I just was like I'm not doing this
anymore I'm not gonna have this some
woman calling me again next year crying
down the phone and it was just too much
of that person is that part though
because people get married
kind of well actually they don't even
get married that young anymore that's
the thing and even if they did also you
could argue but they still signed up for
those for those vows is he is he still a
cheater to this day
it's not my business
you know you're my girl right well it's
mad to me because it's like
how um quickly girls are prepared to
have a child without having marriage and
are willing to leave a relationship with
a child but you would stay with a
relationship if you're married I was
already a single mum so I didn't I I was
already a professional at that so it
wasn't a scary Prospect for me because I
was already a single mother from the age
of 17 so I think the idea of wait what
like so the one the relationship you're
in he's not the baby forever
he's not the father of my child so I've
got a 19 year old adult daughter okay
and then I've got a 10 year old son
and he's not the father because I don't
use that
um he's not the father of my daughter
now he's the father of my son okay okay
I was so confused well it's not really
it's quite simple it's like one child
another child two fathers yeah that
would be a really good episode for
EastEnders
honestly I'm like thinking that'll be
sick no but not just you though like I
do find a lot of um people are like
willing to leave like um relationships
with that's got kids in them as opposed
to leaving it like they take marriage
more seriously but no one wants to get
married
because it's finances like who wants to
spend money on a wedding what guy wants
to spend money on a wedding it takes
them long enough to get there and so I
guess yeah it should be cheaper than
having a kid
not in one go yeah but you don't have to
spent the 180
000 for a child until they're 18. it's
going to say what kind of marriage is
that I was like
spread over 18 years not just one day
and one day for yeah I mean I don't see
it as a waste of money my children
actually as a beautiful
um experience but the issue is why do
people if they've made the step of
actually having a child together and
then they just decide oh well actually
I'm not that happy whatever I mean okay
putting aside cases of like you know of
a terrible abuse and that sort of thing
but in more normal circumstances where
it's just like the Spark's not there
anymore The Vibes like not kind of gone
why is it then that people feel it's
okay to to separate if that makes sense
because it is very damaging to to to to
to kids and I speak as somebody you know
I was from a broken home I've
experienced this kind of stuff I've seen
it in my family and other families
um yeah it seems people can be quite
gung-ho about this these days you know I
also think it's been made easier for
women it has been ladies um when I was
younger I've spoken about this before
that my mum made it sound like I didn't
need a man so it was never in my mind
that oh you are not going to be able to
do it on your own but I I said to my
daughter do not do it with that it need
you need two parents in the same
households like there's moments where my
son does something and I have to send
videos and send pictures when we were
together well he's in the military so he
probably won't be there anyway but
um is it because Society encourages like
feels over responsibility now yeah
um I think it's that element of
happiness again people are too concerned
about how they're feeling rather than
the logical reasons for doing things
it's like you can say what you want
about how happy you are and how happy
the child is If the parents are in
separate homes but factually children
who come from two parent homes do better
off in life factually children who come
from single homes are more likely to be
homeless they're more likely to be in
prison the more likely to do drugs
they're more likely to have addictions
so I just think that this whole
I don't know the way the world is right
now everything's focused on how people
feel and the point is is that feelings
are temporary they last in the moment
they don't last forever but the actions
that you do in life
that does last forever and there's a
domino effect to everything you do so I
think it's just all about sacrifice and
how much you're willing to sacrifice and
I don't think people these days are
willing to sacrifice a lot I think also
we need to
recognize that not everybody is born
super logical not everybody is like it
took me a long time to have this ability
to logically break down in the moment
how my feelings are going to have a
reaction and action some people are just
born logic why why is that was was your
did your parents not teach you to be
logical my mum's a feeler as well in
terms of Myers-Briggs I know some not
many people believe in it were your
parents together no my dad was in um
how much is this pleasure so I know they
weren't together I don't know
okay so but so so there you go so the
reason like the reason that you didn't
have that was because it's it seems like
you didn't have a father in the home
yeah yeah definitely and so it kind of
goes back to what she was saying it's
like a generation of women that put
their feelings before the family and who
had to suffer for it you yeah and then
who had to suffer for your kids because
you weren't taught that and it's a
complete it's a complete cycle yeah
that's what I was saying the other day
that it needs both because the man our
Lord my son's dad by post logic just I'm
like
I'll just send Ethan to his dad I'm like
yeah but sometimes I think people get
into a relationship or people get
married for codependency reasons like
they can't handle Life by themselves so
they need to lean on someone or depend
not a bad thing in marriage
um should be interdependent not
codependent I think you should both be
equally dependent so you can help each
other because what if one day your
husband he's his finances aren't doing
well and obviously you're used to being
dependent on him how are you going to
help him so you have to be equally as um
how does that work in society
does it work well what do you mean women
being equally dependent on their
husbands no does that is that a good
outcome in society the more women work
to more the more equal that didn't have
a good outcome
were there more families or less
families
what do you mean as in like so like the
more women were worked and there's two
incomes the the less families there were
the less women respect men in their
place because they say I don't need you
I don't know so when you say like it's
good I'm asking is it good I mean did it
lead to good outcomes Beyonce and Jay-Z
yeah as a celebrity couple what we
should base everyday relationships off
of well what I'm saying is you should be
independent and be able to take care and
love yourself and know how to deal with
yourself so you can help somebody else
you can't love somebody else until you
love yourself will you talk about
financially codependent or emotionally
then because I think I think overall
emotionally financially mentally as well
that you should be a whole yourself
before getting into a relationship
should have the ability to
like because obviously depending on what
age you meet your partner obviously you
would have worked at some point but then
have that ability to because when you
have kids you know as soon as you push
them out you're not going to be able to
work that's that's what I think is part
of the problem because literally if if
you're there working and I'm there
working then there's two jobs the the
employer has no reason to give me a high
wage because there's there's more people
available for the roles so now that the
price of everything is increased and
everything is um more expensive and I
get less money now you have to be I know
I have to be codependent on my wife it's
not an option anymore do you get what
I'm trying to say whereas if you guys
wasn't working then the employee
admission doesn't necessarily have to um
employ me but if he wants to employ me
he has to pay me a wage that could feed
my family yeah equally but say if you're
going through a hard patch your wife
should be able to have friends friends
wife girlfriend whatever's going on they
should help you until you get back onto
your feet when it comes to finances my
guys got me bro like I'm not gonna ask a
woman to help me with nothing what if
she's your wife yes I'm not gonna ask
her to do anything listen [__] actually
your job your job is to worry about the
household I'm not even gonna let you
know that we're having Financial issues
to that point before it even gets to
that point I'm trying that communication
as well no I'm gonna be like listen here
this month might be a little hard but
I'm going to try my best to literally
sort it out that's good just communicate
because you can't keep your partnering
yeah but why do we we don't need to know
everything well your lights get Switched
Off are the bailiffs at the door
I said you just went to like the worse
it's communication is important but I
don't need to tell me every everything
yeah but I just think as women like
sometimes we think we're and this is the
lesson I had to learn but I think that
we think we're entitled to information
that men are just trying to fix it and
not have us worry about it yeah I agree
I don't want you to think about it
because you're going to be stressed and
your stress is going to stress me out
and I'm going to be less able to sort it
out I'm like listen it's so every month
has been sorted so far right all right
so don't worry this time it's just a
little bit harder for me just rub my
back a little harder you know what I'm
saying
but why would you want to be in a
long-term relationship with someone that
you don't feel comfortable expressing
you're not emotions no no I feel
comfortable I don't I'll tell you
anything but if I know what I'm gonna
tell you is not going to be easy on you
why tell you it do you understand what
I'm trying to say why make my girlfriend
go through or my wife go through the
stress that she doesn't she listen
that's not your stress it's like her
coming to me with every issue she's got
in the house I don't want to hear it
don't come to me with every hitch in the
house because I already got my issues to
sort out do you get what I'm trying to
say so it's not that I lack
communication it's just that some things
is not meant for you to worry about and
it's how you create a Sacred Space you
know you when you go into a relationship
you don't want to be bringing all of
this baggage with you and I think in
order to make a marriage long and
successful you don't need to know every
little detail of what they're doing
where they're going how the finances are
going you create Sacred Space you know
as a woman you you take the load of the
household and the kids you know you
don't need to bother your husband with
every single thing and vice versa the
husband doesn't need to come home and
tell you exactly what's happened at work
and how he's paid the bills but he's
only got said how much I ever left like
it's all about creating a space where
you're just you're in like a comfort
zone together and the fact that men have
this ability where they will go out and
and they will work and they will take
the load of the finances if they're not
telling you if they're a bit short one
month I don't think that's a bad thing I
actually think it's beautiful
would it be less attractive though as
well if the dude is like come going out
to you with every single every single
little thing yeah like if he's if he's
going home and he's like oh like oh I'm
20 quid sure
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
my ex-boyfriend my ex-boyfriend my
childhood sweetheart
oh gosh I can't believe I'm saying this
maybe don't
time
to buy a car
well that's not bad
wow obviously how much was the car it
was a BMW E36 I believe so it's a bit of
a Class E yeah
um
so obviously he paid me back an
installments okay but that's what I mean
what do you think Dynamics
it saves you money
I think it's really important to have
like a friendship yeah who broke up with
who
but not for that reason
um the reason why I broke up with him is
because he called me another girl's name
so did he she's all right no what what
wait what that's crazy anyways wait you
break up with me not because I cheated
but because I called you someone else
no I know who that girl was because he
spoke about that girl in the beginning
of the relationship and I found
something a little bit Seth no but
that's that's my point like even if
that's that's even more reason because
if it's a girl that I used to see then
it's quite easy that I might have
mistaken you you know I actually think
the same thing because I don't know I
just feel like in society we always jump
to the worst case scenario instead of
giving people the benefit of the doubt
what if he just what if what is just a
slip up yeah yeah how long were you two
speaking for oh no we were like
childhood sweethearts yeah and then I
broke up and oh I met him when I was 16.
we got together when I was 17 and then I
broke up with him and I was like 21 22.
so for him to so when did he mention her
because you said at the beginning of
your relationship was that when you were
like six years yeah yeah when you were
21 yeah yeah so that that's a big like
but it's just what it's just one no no
that was
[Applause]
I mean
and it was because he was hanging her
before like hanging out with her before
yeah that's crazy in the car did you
have it all out with him though
afterwards were you like I just asked
him but he started getting a little bit
defensive and I was and I just said to
him like listen like you you I'm not
judging you I'm not telling you off like
I'm not your mom but our five year
relationship is over yeah
so that couldn't even happen but anyways
I just said to him like it's okay like
you can tell me and then he was just
like um
uh because I knew the girl that he was
talking about because they were friends
during like their childhood and then
um they tried to date but it didn't work
because it turned out that she's a
lesbian so I was like fair enough fair
enough and then they stopped speaking I
called you a lesbian you still dumped
him if she's a lesbian that wasn't the
problem wait did he tell you that then
come on we need contacts
what's the contact hmm
so um I was like okay so why are you
hiding the fact that you're hanging out
with her if you're just friends
and then he was just like oh and you
couldn't give me a straight answer so
that's when I was just like okay I'm
just gonna give it time if you want to
open up about something you you'll open
up when you have to
anyways time goes on
and
um he showed me videos on his phone of
them hanging out
they're watching a movie they're under a
blanket together eating Chinese food and
I was just like he sent you the video he
didn't sent me it he just showed me on
his phone he was like see we're not
doing anything and I was just like
something is just over here it didn't
help his case
you started this story I'm not saying
you you broke up with him
yeah this isn't I gave him time I gave
him time because I was just like it
could be a slip up you never know but
then
stuff didn't you know it wasn't adding
up and then I was just like you know
what but ultimately but ultimately if
she was a lesbian with a going down to
her anyway I mean
but this leads on to be honest I thought
you were going to say that he said your
name like said that girl's name while
you were banging us yeah that's that's
where I thought the story was going it
doesn't really seem that serious yeah
well well uh
as a man or woman are you allowed to
like two people yeah like if I'm going
out with you am I allowed to like
someone else of course I mean if you're
in like a hardcore committed
relationship and you're planning on
getting married and practicing
exclusivity yeah then that's a bit of a
disrespect but if you're in an open
relationship there's a disrespect for me
to like someone naturally like like
something I can't help yeah you can't
help how you feel that you feel you
can't help like attraction isn't a
choice so if you walk past someone hot
and you're like God damn Oh you mean
that I thought you meant as in like
physically do something you're seeing
someone else
of course right if he liked another
girl's pictures on Instagram I'll be
like like that I mean like am I I'm
attracted to her am I allowed to be
attracted to another woman
well in a
relationships I have a question actually
let me did you have guy friends during
this
okay so you had male friends we were mad
at him for having a female friend oh no
it wasn't like that okay it was it was
like
no more a bit of a female friend do you
see what I mean there's layers there's
layers yeah okay did you did you find
out for sure that they hooked up or like
did something
you know I believe for sure like you
know they did I believe in female
intuition and I know
because it's too graphic
okay okay
so when I was with him I we didn't have
to be graphic let's be sure
I just realized something like obviously
with my body like um
anyways when I but compared to how my
health was in the relationship to
compared to how my health was outside
the relationship if you know what I mean
like I was clean outside the
relationship but inside that
relationship I wasn't so he he hadn't
created a Sacred Space like exactly yeah
yeah he was he was disrespectful space
with the lesbian
he was a community God damn man if
you're gonna if you anyway if you're
gonna do some um strap up in it like you
know what I'm saying like well you
shouldn't be dripping that anyway what
wait hold on like can I just be like
could just be frank here if you're
willing to have a kid outside of
relationship here
like isn't it like
incumbent on me to not necessarily take
you seriously because you don't want to
lock me down in terms of marriage yeah
so that means you're you're willing to
leave me at any point in time if you
have a disagreement with me or you're
not really feeling what I'm doing so
there's a lack of attachment there so
why do you worry about why are you
worried about who I'm with like who else
I'm with who are you talking to here not
just in general oh why would a girl be
worried about who I'm with
um
depends on the situation what like if
she knows that you like her in a sexual
way if you've been together like five or
six years I think like you you know I
think he would be bothered about who I
was with like whether we were in our not
in a committed relationship like yeah I
mean I can't judge you though and I
can't be like you know like I could
think do you know what my girl there's
no way I've been with my girl for six
years and she ain't slipped up once like
do you know what I mean like thinking in
2023 but if she's able to I don't want
to say yeah
I don't think there's anyone that
doesn't cheat say that again like do you
not think there are people out here that
exist that don't cheat yeah of course
but where are they were they wearing
fairy wings or something like that
I believe are they fasting right now
like what are we talking about like
she's not trying to say like what's
what's going on like do I know the games
so anytime like I'm just prepared for
you the cheaty to cheating you can be
prepared had but at the same time if you
res there's preparation and being like
realistic like I wasn't blind to the
fact of who my son's father was and I'm
still not blind if I got back with him I
wouldn't be like oh no like I I see you
I know you yeah and now but I think his
point is like cheating is something that
can be worked through and we act like
it's not yeah
and so it's like it kind of goes back to
the me me culture where it's like my
feelings before anything and like you
know you weren't married you don't think
you had kids or anything right oh no no
yeah yeah but so I think it's a little
different outside of a really like when
you're dating you can pick what you want
which you don't want but like when it
comes to having kids it's like it's
supposed to be the family before you all
right what's my question and Mary yeah I
was gonna be interesting question you're
married yeah yeah you find out that your
your misses yeah it's been
game with our work husband oh hell no
yeah oh so you leave it why not please
and you see a video of her oh my God I'm
giving him is that what happened to you
they didn't have sex though
and he's holding her hair are you
getting are you are you getting a
divorce oh my God you've got kids as
well you got kids I'm not good but isn't
it okay
he just said wait wait let him answer go
ahead I'm doing something in it
so wait your answers you're gonna cheat
back no no he's gonna commit a crime I'm
gonna commit
all right this is crime movie I think
that's the male team yeah it is
so much I don't condone either the
internet gets this wrong I don't I don't
say do either however I think female
cheating is a hundred times worse than
male cheating because they mean it but
it could still because I mean it this
difference if for the kids yeah if his
kids can't try if she's sober and she
does it and there's like explicit stuff
going on then it's hard harder to take
than if she was just doing a little
missionary like she watches is that what
happened to you by any chance
oh wow good imagination yeah
I'm doing something man but that to my
point though it's like I wouldn't like
okay why do we necessarily have the same
rules for modern day relationships yeah
than traditional relationships like back
in the day yes we expect everyone to
stay together because we were going to
get married now everyone's doing their
own thing everyone's independent where
so why do you still expect me to be like
an old school guy like that's not that's
faithful in that I don't get it I didn't
expect that okay oh you don't expect
okay I didn't expect I don't expect
anything whatever somebody like I can't
expect because that's where people get
let down and hurt because their
expectations my expectations back then
were so high of like what my feelings
needed so I have a I have a question
this might this might be offensive
so so is it
is it fair of you like would you want to
have someone that's monogamous now
um
that's uh interesting question
I believe that men can choose to be
monogamous do I believe that it's easy
for a man to be monogamous no no I'm
asking so we'll do your next
relationship
um
I would want that yeah do you think it's
fair to want that when you have kids
from two different fathers
yeah
what does he get out of the deal
well it depends on what he you mean into
monogamy I wouldn't be cheating
obviously and if he wants an open
relationship because I've explored the
idea of polyamory and polygamy as well
and I've looked at all the Dynamics I
wouldn't write it out and I wouldn't
rule it out and Rule anything out it's a
discussion that would have to have
depending on the relationship with that
person because I just I just find it
that like ladies they're more of the
kind of people that would do one at a
time one at a time so it would be like
she'll be so quick to leave the
relationship if she wanted to get rid of
me and start something fresh which is
completely okay but for me how I work is
different as a man you know what I'm
trying to say I'm not trying to I'm not
trying to leave my girl because yeah you
know what I'm trying to say so it's
different how we we view sex in terms of
of genders yeah but men get castigated
regardless if they step outside yeah
let's say I mean I don't think you
should do that in marriage honestly but
if we're in this relationship quote
unquote yeah we're together so you would
rather come from like say you would say
that your mom polygamous then oh
everyone knows this already I don't know
I don't know this
I'm very educate educate the panel tell
us
that's an assumption that we would know
all right so I I'm of the opinion that
I would rather have wives with a s than
have
girls yeah I don't see why if I was to
ask all four of you girls right now is
it okay for me to be single and sleep
with 20 girls if they're completely
consentful if I want to you'd be like
yeah yeah yeah so why can't I do it four
why is that when I look after I wanna
give them a house I want to marry them I
want to nurt why what's the problem I
have friends that do that can I ask why
why wouldn't you be satisfied with one
wife
what do you mean like would you be
satisfied with one wife would you be
satisfied with eating vanilla flavor ice
cream all your life
what about how you view women how have
you no that's no I'm just asking your
question ice cream is good what if that
woman that you um was not vanilla she
was like some spicy chili Taco
that's literally vanilla it could be it
could be anything I'm not gonna like
okay so I love I love water because it
hydrates me I wouldn't I would die if I
did not have water it's it replenish me
like like sometimes my lips are so dry I
just need it and it keeps me alive but I
don't mean I don't want to get a Miranda
sometimes like I'm not I'm not gonna
live on Marinda but you know what I'm
trying to say like yeah like what you're
saying but sometimes you can get that
with the same chick like she can be be a
nurse one night the next night she could
tell you what
yeah it's still the same video there's a
phrase yeah there's this phrase that
they say it's like you can't compete
with new
so it doesn't really yeah because it so
it doesn't really matter what you do new
is still that's what when I asked my
previous
um why like this was like years after we
weren't together I was like why do you
do it he would say it's just different
vagina yeah it's like oh okay was he
emotionally monogamous to you
I mean he's not the most he's really
really logical so I mean he's not like
outwardly emotional anyway so I mean he
had a whole nother relationship though
yeah yeah but I mean what I'm saying is
that yes obviously he wasn't emotionally
monogamous to me because he did have
another whole relationship but I mean
like for me to look at and be like oh
he's really in love with that person I
mean does it hurt like because because
it's like does it hurt being finding out
that someone because
if I'm going on for the same example
with the water just because I like
Miranda that does not diminish water the
feelings I have for water in any way of
course not but I'm a woman I'm not a man
so for me to think like that it took me
many years to really put myself in the
mind of a man I was thinking from my
heart not from a man's penis
you know smart though the idea of having
four wives might sound good yeah until
you've got to maintain all four wives
what's what's worse and all four houses
like to maintain like so you've got a
kid with all four women you've got to
maintain four different households yeah
the set is the same baby mothers well
actually that's a headache I wouldn't
even want to sign up today instead of
putting your money in an ISO Bank you
you put it you in a house and you get
the wife it's like almost employing an
employee when you have four wives you
can't make it with it for you they're
trying to think of a business it sounds
like a headache I mean to be fair like
that's been done throughout all of
history always and they say wait what do
you mean headache though a thousand
years ago 17 men reprodu or 17 women
reproduce for every one man so that's
the way they've always done it I'm not
for like I don't want to do that but
it's kind of like how am I supposed to
look at the world and say don't do what
you've always done yeah so like how can
you maintaining four different
relationships no I mean they did no but
think about it this way if I'm pissed
off with Michelle
I'm not pissed off with Angela so me and
Michelle don't need to break up I just
take a couple days out because I'm over
here and I'm saying she knows I'm not
all over the roadsides she knows exactly
where I am she knows how to contact me
she could come and come over and say hi
the kids are playing together or
whatever yeah I'm out I'm on the next
one what's the most amount of girls
you've spoken to at one time
yo
[Music]
yo listen there was a point in time
listen that was called Mr Mr message me
you got me called I would just copy
paste that message wow
the same message bro okay sorry when I
say talking to like actively going on
dates hooking up with whatever God damn
um
she's I don't even know she should say
this bro
um
a couple a couple just two a couple
hours okay more more or less than more
or less than seven final seven is a lot
that's no no okay so more than three
around around three and were you dating
them all like actively dating or was it
just like hookups Netflix and chill it
was a mixture everyone had their
different stages in the relationship and
were they aware of that or not all of
them what at some point some of them
is that polygamy because isn't polygamy
meant to be extremely open honest oh
that's that's basically me back in the
days oh okay okay no I'm on marriage I'm
on emerging
how many are you married to that's this
far none what do you mean what I was
just asking no I'm not married listen
you said I'm on a marriage thing so
that's why I was like how many have you
got because if you're gonna get four
you've got you've got time you know but
I don't think I don't think it's fair
that I marry one now while I'm in the
situation I'm in and then when I'm
extremely wealthy which I know I will be
to then marry another one well can you
give her that could you give it a heads
up first I'm gonna be wealthy one day
yeah and then there's gonna be more of
you yeah but when the second one comes
she's like listen I I I can't do that
before this time when you are going
spend our money on this one right if
they're okay with polygamy they'll know
about it from the beginning a lot of
women are okay with polygamy a lot of
women say they're okay with it but
saying something and actually
being okay with it is two different
things it's like a lot of girls will be
like yeah I don't mind just linking and
yeah we could just do this linking thing
and then after two solid Congo men then
after you know I'm saying will it swing
left to right all of a sudden yeah she
wants the wifey now I'm curious
um who here has ever been in a talking
stage oh
I get talking
what the hell is that
you never know what you mean like um
dating like dating hooking up but
without a relationship oh yeah that's
what we do know
what do you mean I'm not in a
relationship have you ever done that
with a guy yeah yeah I mean like that's
how me and my son started I think I
thought that would a chick
oh hang on a minute the the girl that
was under the duvet yeah you liked her
yeah
yes yes with a girl yeah yeah because
it's interesting because girls will say
they're not like they they only will do
monogamy but when you're doing a talking
stage it's basically non-monogamy
but I'm not talking to anybody I'm not
talking to anybody yeah yeah but he
probably is yeah he's 100 I think so so
in a way it's like just a different way
of not doing I think I think I think
anecdotally as well I think that happens
a lot I think I think women I think a
lot of girls will do that they might
have a boyfriend but they'll be like
talking to some other dudes you know
wait whatever but that's cheap that's
cheap yeah she's still got no physical
well yeah no I don't situations
he's right though because a lot of times
no no like well girls will have a
boyfriend but still be getting attention
from other dudes because we'll be the
first to judge men for cheating but we
don't talk about how we get attention
from other dudes while we're in
relationships like oftentimes girls will
have open Instagrams oftentimes girls
will be accepting messages from other
guys oftentimes girls will be dressing
really provocatively and going out and
then we'll we'll point the finger at the
guys and say oh well you cheated well I
mean you kind of cheated too by doing
that bad and that I just posting bikini
pics on Instagram acting like you're not
just
no but I just think it depends on like
the boundaries within your own
relationship because if you had an open
Instagram account before you got
together or he saw he was sleeping with
other girls before you got together
when you get in a relationship if you
come to the agreement that we're
monogamous and he doesn't want you to
have it yeah but no no but I'm saying if
if you to the agreement that okay he
doesn't want you to have an open
opinions then yeah that's right but this
is but this is the problem this is why
men get a bad deal today because men are
told they can't have standards because
if a guy says close your Instagram you
can't go to the club he's controlling
he's toxic and so and so men are always
told they can't tell the girl anything
but then why don't you seek out mad
women who have a private Instagram
account already
[Laughter]
you know what is this is a statistic
that men tend to marry I don't know if
this is true correct me if I'm wrong men
tend to marry women who are plain Jane
like they get settled with a plain Jane
wow I think guys will marry who they can
get to be honest for the most part I
mean I think if he can if he can get the
you know the 10 he's going to marry the
10. I think the reason guys for the most
part do that is because that's what they
reckon they can achieve yeah but when
you say 10 do you mean like looks or do
you mean like in terms of no I mean well
no but to the question what does a guy
prefer to marry a plain Jane I'm saying
I think I think in reality the guy's
going to want to marry the most
attractive world you can yeah I do take
your point though there's a distinction
between do you mean in terms of looks
and in terms of in terms of personality
but I think I mean I've changed so yeah
I used I used to think I would want like
the most beautifulest girl in the world
whatever but now I know I don't want the
most beautiful girl in the world because
like that comes with a lot of stress bro
that's so much stress especially if you
want four like walking down the road
with a girl that's nice it's like bro no
it's not my sister no no you can't
attract to it no like do you know I mean
it's like bro it's like a constant
constant constant forget about him he
ain't doing it it's like bro
forget that I'm just trying to get the
normal thing right you know yeah
the normal it's certainly a piece of
advice that gets given to guys in the
men's like online dating whatever you
know in terms of your wife you shouldn't
be looking look shouldn't be the main
priority and and that's correct anyway
isn't it really because let's face it if
you talk about getting married it's got
to be a partnership it's got to be
something that works so I think that it
all boils down to it everyone finds that
level in it yeah but I think that that
is
truth is I reckon most guys would want
the you know the the swimsuit model
who's also a really nice person and
who's also really really modest and
doesn't do Instagram with a swimsuit
model body yes I find that attractive
though like if my if my man my man
posted a picture on Instagram
and he looked really good and he had
thousands of likes and people commenting
I'll be like yes like go you like your
practice
but the problem is that average chicks
get more attention than a top one
percent dude not only that they're gonna
say go go Lads yeah go and you go boy
but forget it's like yo when you come
check me blood like what like yo long
time no Michelle where you been like I'm
saying like you know what man uh you
know what I'm saying yeah there's a
difference you know there's a complete
difference if a man's got his top off
he's like oh you might see a little CD
little you know um tongue out Emoji
whatever I mean I'm saying by the end of
the day you still want to get churched
so you're making yourself available for
the guy that you think is nice to come
and chat to you huh
but isn't taking like a guy taking a
really nice picture and posting it on
his Instagram for obviously attention
what kind of picture to her first try
yeah yeah like guys taking first track
pictures he's weird anyway
it's like solo yeah
online then
um I literally got like eight pictures
on my Instagram yeah but each each and
every one was like
um uh era for me
so so when I look at it I think ah that
one was was there I was chilling with
these Lots I had the best time ever here
when we went there we did that that one
was in Trinidad when I remember that
that one's just like that oh this one
was here it was like me and my cousin
and my friend it's like that's the Three
Musketeers boom boom boom I'll always
love them boom that's like not for I
don't care what girl like I'll walk on
the road and chat to go just standard
it's not yeah I don't need you to look
at my Instagram in fact I'm trying to
ask for your number do you know what I
mean not not like
um
what about did you guys answer what do
you guys believe
in divorce and for what reasons
well
he's divorcing
and why is that the couple either or
the people that are married there's a
difference between a man divorce and a
woman divorcing okay tell me what what
are what are valid reasons for a divorce
the main reason why men would leave
um should the woman leave if he cheats
yeah I think she should you think she
should what if it's a one-night stand
she still should
yeah
because you got you got if you've got
court brothers that's it don't get
caught I thought a minute ago there was
no you am I ever I missed something no
that was my thing
yeah that was me okay I asked their
opinions no that's their opinion okay
what about you do I believe in divorce
yeah what were your sins I don't really
believe in marriage to be honest
no I mean I think if you get married and
you make those vows and you made that
commitment then I think that you should
for the most part I think you should
stay in it really I don't think you
should just and this is the whole
problem that we've had over the last
slight few decades and since no fault
divorce came in it become a lot easy to
divorce no I think you should if you if
you could have made that commitment I
think you should hang in there for sure
don't cheat on your wife didn't mean
let's get another one
what do you think that divorce for me
would be the worst nightmare so
yeah like once you make them vows what
if she cheats you stand no okay
this is the worst nightmare but
obviously that's the only thing that
will cut that can't run do you think do
you think she should leave if you cheat
she'll have you right too yeah because
it's a choice isn't it got me control of
my own decisions so if I made that
choice I'm prepared to take the
consequences yeah man
yeah because again equally if you sign
up for it you're signing on that dotted
line you're saying you know I'm going to
be you know effectively I'm saying I'm
going to be monogamous to you you should
also adhere to that because that's what
you promised you know I have a I have a
friend and I just feel like we never
talk about these stories like I have a
friend um her parents cheated and or not
her parents her um Dad cheated on her
mom and he was really bad he was like a
Serial cheater too it was like cheating
with everyone basically and they ended
up like working through it
um and like she was happier at the end
she passed away but they were like
married like 40 years in the last like
10 years they were together they were
really really happy there was this whole
issue was in there we've talked we've
obviously touched all this already about
is it worse when a woman cheats as
opposed to a when a guy cheats and I
think
I mean look you know any female viewers
of this are gonna flame me but I think
I can conceive of it being easier to
work through that way around than maybe
if the wife has cheated on the guy a lot
of times and then working through that I
think that's seems to me a bigger ask
for that guy to work through that um I
agree I think cheating is different for
a man and for a woman yeah because guys
will cheat with anything they'll cheat
with that they'll cheat with a hole in
the wall
marriages marriage is a bit different
because it's like you don't even need to
get married in 2023 so why you you're
committing to something that's big so
it's either for me personally I think
either you're religious
or like you you um you're from a very
traditional family well that's the point
I was sort of jokingly making because I
sort of think on the other hand why
would you sign up for it yeah if you're
not you know unless you're prepared if
you sign up to say yeah like you're
going to take half if I [__] up and then
you [__] up like you're an idiot exactly
you know what I mean like it's like I
don't I don't expect her not to to leave
like you just gave her the the keys to
leave right or do what that footballer
did and just put everything on your mums
like I just think like they used to work
through stuff you know like they used to
actually try to figure stuff out where
now it's like he slips up once and she's
gone yeah and it's not the man doing it
it's the women leave 80 of the time so
the women are the ones giving up and
then it's weird because they're rewarded
it's like you're the quitter why do you
get rewarded for being a quitter I don't
agree with the reward part they do I'm
just saying you could you could leave if
you want but I don't know about the
reward partner I didn't say anything
about that where they get paid monthly
and I was like what I should have got
married
um yeah it's wild that you have to pay
for a fully grown human like why not
says divorce is a matter of the question
when children matter first I fail to
understand
there's a hundred dollar Super Chat
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is a matter of question when
children met or first I failed to
understand it was just a statement that
was a statement he's saying he doesn't
understand divorce when the children
come first
um if you want to play the next video
blessing
that guy was a genius though
I will be suggesting it to my son
okay and all the tips and all the tips
from the show for sure
don't worry mommy's not gonna take
anything
your mom is Never Gonna Leave but your
wife
genius I won't even put it that way to
him though is there some other legal way
of doing it like some kind of yeah of
course offshore company no no no just
open a trust yeah if you probably open a
company to to manage to trust and then
open another company that manages the
company that manages to the company did
I divorce my husband I divorced my
husband because I was making a certain
amount of money
I thought I didn't need him anymore I
divorced my husband because I had this
senior position at work and thought I
held the same position at home I
divorced my husband because I thought I
was better than him because I had my
degree now I divorced my husband because
I thought a successful marriage meant I
was here and he was down here that is
not success that's [__] sickness I
found myself divorced and out there
looking for love in all the wrong places
[__] this one and that one and that
one and that one and this one and that
one and my body count going up and my
value going down I'm just gonna call it
like a TI is all the time oh
my God a a relationship been building a
life with them I should have stayed
married to my husband I felt like I was
on this dark road with no street lights
pitch dark and I couldn't find my way
and didn't know which way to go I felt
lost I felt like I was walking barefoot
on that dark road with pebbles and Hot
Rocks sticking my foot I felt hurt I
felt alone because every time he and
that one and this one and that one left
my bed I was alone all by myself and
which was supposed to be soft and
comfortable comfortable for me my pillow
it was now filled with tears I should
not have left my husband
divorce my husband why did I divorce my
husband I divorced my husband because I
was making a certain amount of money I
divorced my husband because I thought I
didn't need him anymore I divorced my
husband because I had this senior
position at work and thought I held the
same position I divorced my husband
because I
what did you guys think of that video
I liked her honesty that's for sure
um
hindsight's a hell of a thing isn't it I
guess for her yeah I think she was quite
graphic and
but like if you divorce someone or you
break up with someone it doesn't
necessarily mean that your body count
has to go up well no but
a lot yeah what would happen are you are
you a nun after that sex again just
alone forever you're gonna look for love
and like she said like probably because
of her age people are not taking her
seriously so they're pumping and dumping
and she's left there as she said crying
into a pillow so she left her man
because she got money she because she
felt like [__] superiority I think a lot
I've had a lot of that happens because
you're more in your masculine so she
felt like a man was somehow beneath her
she got she outranked him that's wild so
she outranked him in the house as well
that women are more likely to divorce
their husbands after they get a
promotion at work yeah so don't stop too
many princes
sales
um yeah award
uh what well what did you think of the
video
I thought it was outrageous like I don't
know
I think it's really sad that that
happens and I know that it's common
but I just think it's devastating like
just because you're doing well at
something why is your thought not then I
can't wait to share this with the person
I love rather than this person is now
beneath me I'm the [__] I'm Gonna Leave
You I'm gonna go out like I'm not being
funny like that woman is not young why
was she thinking no offense but why was
she thinking anyone is actually going to
be interested you're divorced you
clearly care more about money than you
do about love and building a future
I I just think it's completely
delusional I don't see any sense or
logic in anything she said apart from
the fact that she took accountability
for her actions and realized actually I
had it better off like maybe she was
getting attention you know like when
yeah she was out and she's in a nice car
and she was maybe getting attention from
younger guys I don't know if this is
just or maybe maybe she was around men
that made more money at work yeah yeah
and she was thinking oh I need to be
what were you gonna say no I was gonna
say well I didn't say the age that she
you know like divorced her husband did
that could have been like years ago when
she was younger and now this is her like
speaking um you know from experience but
it obviously it wasn't a logical
decision though was it I mean she just
obviously I think the important the
point is she lost the feels yeah I mean
she got like high off the attention high
off the money it was impulsive decision
I don't necessarily think that that was
a good decision that she made and I feel
like you do see this a lot especially
with for example like with like
celebrity men when they have like a
woman before they come up and then when
they come up you'll see that's when they
start to like cheat and like DM these
Instagram models and whatever whatever
they cheated before they just didn't
know about it yeah maybe I love that
there's you know it's got even more
options it's more but so so I'm just
saying to you shouldn't I okay I was
gonna say to you shouldn't I be able to
do that though
so say for example you met me I was
earning 50k now I'm earning 50 million
don't you think I should I mean do you
but so do you think that woman was right
to leave her husband
um
it's not for me to say if she was right
or wrong what's more important to me is
that she's telling you so young people
could hear it
and make that that same decision before
they get to that point because in in the
sense that she was working so she's
working in a career she's a career woman
so the man felt the need to be with her
when she was working on my career
did you get it so when she when she got
her money up and she's willing to leave
and as she said the guy he went on to
move on to another girl you know what I
was thinking if I was a guy and I was
just logically trying to solve this I
just wouldn't support my wife's career
at all like if she wanted to do
something like that it's easy for me
it's easy for me the promotion you're
more likely to leave no you're not it's
easy for me to get a go after if I've
got more money and she's got more money
it's easy for me to get a woman so I
don't care if you leave or not I'll just
get another girl and I feel like it's
kind of necessary for men to be like
that as well like I feel like we need
men to sometimes drag us back down to
earth like you're not doing that like
you have to have faith in your man that
he knows what's best for you as a unit
as a couple instead of oh I'm an
individual and I'm going to do my
individual thing and I'm a boss [__]
and all that but I don't think it should
be seated
that progression if it meant that we
were going to be grounded
because I value love more than I value
money isn't that feeling isn't that more
based on his insecurity though shouldn't
he level up I mean yeah of course
her point is trusting his decision
making in a relationship so she's not
even necessarily like I'm assuming
you're not necessarily just talking
about work but like sometimes as women
like we we think we can do get ahead of
ourselves because we're so emotional
yeah and sometimes it's like kind of
nice to have a guy say no no you're not
like oh I want to go butt naked to the
club oh no yeah
so I'm talking about like holding you
back yeah I think it was aggressive well
it depends if it's something that you're
really really passionate about and and
they can I just think like you gotta
trust that the person you're with if you
genuinely know they love you like if
you're doing something that you're
already passionate about they're gonna
support that I don't think a man is
gonna stop his woman from doing
something unless he genuinely believes
it's in hers and his best interest to do
that it would be like okay she's you're
in copiers
God Bless but it's like if she if she
got a promotion at work and it was going
to require her to work an extra 15 hours
a week but they have kids it's like yeah
maybe that would be good for her career
but it's not good for the family and the
guy should be looking out for the family
Above All Else and I'd be kind of
worried if he like if we did have
children I would be kind of worried if I
did get a promotion and it required me
to work 15 more hours and he went yeah
that's fine
that would be a turn off I'd be like
what you don't want me to be at home
with our children what if he was like
okay if you want to do that then I'll
reduce my owls at work so that he can
it's hard for me to say because I know I
wouldn't want to do that so it's hard
for me to to speak outside of my
personal feelings because I'm a woman so
I'm emotional like I can't I can't say I
don't I just don't have that drive to
view a career over my my children and
being home with them and so yeah I just
I don't know I think I wouldn't suggest
any woman I I think when you bring kids
into the scenarios a completely
different conversation but if there's no
kids in general relationships I think
ladies
so if it's something
yeah and he says no don't go don't go
for it I'd be like that's a rude it
would depend because if it was about
money that's what that's that's what the
whole topic though she left her mind
because she was making more money didn't
it
so if you had an opportunity to make
more money or to stay with my man and he
was insecure about that and said no
don't go for that because you're going
to earn too much
well it's insecurity that he wouldn't
want me to work to make more money yeah
but why is that insecurity why is why is
that insecurity that's what I'm a bit
lost with that's what this whole thing
is based on to not want it so the man is
insecure specifically make more money
than her like there's no other factors
other than the fact if you're if you're
getting a promotion seeing that he in a
situation where it's not about kids it's
not about anything else it's just purely
the fact that he does not want you to
make more money than him my question
would be like then I wouldn't do it like
I just I don't know I don't think like
that I don't remember her point is that
she's with a guy that she trusts so the
whole point is you trust her why would
you trust that judgment that's Madness
that's what trust is
but but like she wouldn't be with a guy
that she doesn't trust but yeah that's
the whole point like all right all right
so you all said to me yeah you're you're
doing copy sales yeah printing sales and
your company says you don't want that
promotion listen listen listen
we're going to double your salary you've
got an amazing opportunity for you by it
means you gotta move to a different city
yeah if my boyfriend or husband didn't
want me to do it I wouldn't do it
wow
why is that so amazing babe yeah I'm
sorry
actually okay
if it's basically if it's based purely
exactly but it's like the same with my
dad if my dad if I got a promotion it
doubled my salary my dad didn't want me
to do it I wouldn't do it because I
trust my dad I have respect so cute but
purely there's no reason he just doesn't
want you to take that promotion fine you
know my mom wasn't it it's funny my mom
was in a similar situated my mom was in
a similar situation and that's how she
got 10 kids in a mansion baby
seriously she was my mom was dating my
dad there are two different schools she
really liked her first school she had
more opportunity at her first school and
my dad basically told her to either find
to either move to him or find a new
boyfriend and she moved and she got then
she got 10 kids she got
they built a multi-million dollar
business together like because she knew
that my dad was it's all about this
instant gratification thing like you're
saying about like would I take the
double salary or my man saying no like
that's that's on the basis of instant
gratification right like the reasons the
reasons why like it's the whole based on
this but what's the reason matter if you
trust that decision yeah because what I
mean if you're picking the guy it's it's
like that's that's yeah that you see a
future with yeah nice investment delayed
gratification that's investment time
right and I'm investing in my
relationship right she left her man
because she was making more money right
so in that scenario
the man's going to be insecure no she
didn't have to leave him she wanted to
leave him because she thought she was
over him
and I just wouldn't do that I also think
a lot of guys perhaps wouldn't be
insecure about it because they wouldn't
think of it up front do you know what I
mean because I reckon there's a load of
guys out there who aren't going to think
oh she's earning more money than me
she's gonna immediately leave me do you
know what I mean I think that's a red
like a red pill truth that might come to
bite them you know what I'm saying like
I think a lot of guys would be just like
oh no dude you just go do you do you
yeah I don't even think the majority of
men they wouldn't even think
it seems mad to me to hold anyone back
in life
selling printers in this scenario like
this is the thing about passion if it
was something I was passionate about and
it was a good cause about it then I
would have to have some kind of
discussion about it but ultimately if he
doesn't want me doing it I'm not gonna
do it well it's it's actually crazy to
me that you don't think that any guy
would be worth giving up a career yeah
like to me that's crazy you don't think
there's any guy that's worth that no of
course but it depends it depends on the
situation right so obviously if it's
purely based on right you're going to
get a promotion and out earn me
therefore you I don't want you to take
that job that's crazy that's crazy
that's exactly that's all I'm talking
about
she said it wasn't about money she said
he's being cautious and there might be
others like that's what I thought you
were getting at yeah she was like I
trust him I trust his decision making
and so why wouldn't I trust my partner
plus I'd like to be with a guy who I
think is more intelligent than me so I
trust that they can make good decisions
for me and thus for us so are you are
you equal to your man no depends in what
sense can you specify well you tell me
what in what sense
when women say they're equal to men in
that sense it's different we're
different so you can't make you can't
you can't com there can't be a
comparison
I think it's equal different terms of
you know there's two halves of a
relationship so your two parts that make
up one whole
but all right can I can I give you the
hypothetical settings then
in the hypothetical settings you as a
woman you pick a man that's taller than
you stronger than you richer than you
smarter than you
I'm not saying we're equal so you're not
equal I said we're equal in the sense of
your two parts of a relationship but you
were talking about equality in the sense
of who makes the decisions who deals
with the finances who ultimately is the
the leader of the unit that is your
relationship right so if you're if I'm
the leader of the relationship isn't it
incumbent on me anyway to tell you like
what is the best decision for our family
absolutely absolutely right no I'm just
going along I'm following the chain so
why would it be weird for the husband to
make that decision I don't think it
would be weird that I trust my husband's
decision I think he's asking are you
asking beard beard gang
I think we're talking about two complete
different things here okay pretty much
like my whole point yeah it was based on
you mean anyone you you're in a
relationship with your man you've got an
opportunity to make more than him that
makes him feel insecure and he says to
you you're presuming but this is what is
but so I have a question what if it was
about I don't want you around those guys
all day
like there's still like because I worked
in copier sales yeah it's mostly guys I
was the only girl in the office what if
it's just you know I don't think there's
only me and one other one
usually do hard jobs
sales guys are sharks as well right
sharks what do you mean
they're top salesman they're very
they know well the best sale those best
sales person is um the other girl she's
really good at what she does
um but like my director like he's very
sort of 80 style sales like he walks
into a place but so would you think that
was acceptable if he said you know what
I I don't think you being around a group
of guys every day all day is going to be
good for a relationship acceptable or
not acceptable
foreign
if he says all right I don't want you
working at that company
so to you it's all about bargaining so
it's about what do I get from this
decision so if he's going to say to you
don't work at that company and he's
going to look after you and I need a
reason and that's different so so are
you saying that I'm just trying to
understand your your perspective so
you're saying that if he says I don't
want you at work because I don't want
you around all of these guys and you
said well what's he gonna do to make up
for that I don't view it like that I
don't need something to be made up for
like how are you going to live yeah how
am I going to live what do you mean
well I would trust that if he's telling
me he doesn't want me to work that
that's because he's going to look after
me otherwise why would he tell me well
then that's what you get out of it
dictatorship yeah exactly I'm not
expecting the way you said it just made
me think you're still getting something
out of perspective it needs to be
something out of you he shouldn't just
tell you oh yeah like quit your job now
and then you just do it like of course
he has to give you some sort of
reasoning behind him yeah so she said
what if you as a woman just said you
know what let me look at other jobs that
are more female like that are work with
women more yeah like isn't that it's all
about negotiations if you don't care
about your job then fine I mean
hairdressers but I think it just goes
back to like like what what matters to
what matters to her is it is it the man
or the job what's more important is it
the family or the job isn't that one a
little bit tricky though because if he
says oh there's all these other dudes in
the office so I'm not happy with that
does that is that they're a danger
that's gonna make him look a little bit
insecure
do you know what I mean
like because because if he was like the
Apex Alpha wouldn't he just say well I
don't care about these other things
you know he's leaving their wife just
because they got a promotion though I
don't know I don't know I think there's
Nuance to it I'd have to you know it it
would all depend on the context of the
situation if he didn't like the people
that I was around
and he gave good reason for it then like
it's fine but I guess maybe a little bit
if it was just completely unjustified he
had no idea what I was like at work this
is exactly what I was talking about yeah
so I would need reasoning it's not like
I just go okay I'm gonna quit tomorrow
like but I would I I know that I just I
wouldn't pick a guy that wouldn't be
able to give me a logical exercise I
think the logical reason of like oh
you're gonna have to work extra 15 hours
a week that that is is solid because
he's like no no I don't want you doing
yeah I want to you know here with us I
think the work husband is solid too you
don't really marriages ended divorce
doesn't work no again I get it no I get
it no so completely completely I'm just
I'm just saying from a woman's point of
view though could that not come across
as being a little bit needed because
she's a little hang on a minute most
women would take that as needy I don't
think that mindset is common yeah but
how many how many men how many women
stay in relationships because they have
a work husband
mm-hmm
oh my God
[Laughter]
it wasn't me specifically but this guy
at my old workplace
he literally slept with all the members
in the gym just to keep his
um classes popular like his Fitness
classes popular but he tried to control
the situation and say to the women these
married women ah just let's just keep it
between us so he was the work husband
not for one but for all those ladies in
that Fitness class
yes yeah but the day he got the day he
got snitched on and people started
complaining oh he got fired well yeah so
the work husband this was like work
husband on steroids he was everybody's
working with me
unreal unreal no but relationships do
stay together if the woman is satisfied
right
Define satisfied oh so you're saying she
cheats with the husband at work and gets
what she needs from him and then goes
home to the other husband yeah so she
doesn't need to leave so how many
relationships have stayed because of the
work husband as opposed to left because
of the work husband 70 of women have to
finish themselves off so I mean it makes
me wait what what's this 17. give me
they go in the bedroom and check
like after they've had sex with their
partner because like not a lot of well
only 30 of women can come from
penetration they then end up having to
finish themselves off because they've
already pleased their husband and their
Partners so 70 of women tend to please
themselves after all yeah so am I the
surveys are also one I know one-sided
it's like what if they ask the man about
how the women were in bed well men men I
mean technically I please myself anyway
I'm pleasing myself you're not doing
nothing I'm doing it so I'm pleased
um is that why people divorce it's
because
do you think that's a valid reason for
divorce your husband's not good at sex
you should know that before you get
married to be fair
downhill after yeah what but what if
like people obviously they believe in um
no sex before marriage and then when
they get married they're like oh my what
is this
I think it is a reason for divorce
actually because I saw and this is a bad
quality of stats here but I saw
something uh just the other day saying
that actually
um Falls in male libido or one of the
key reasons why marriage is owned
because the guy goes off sex the woman's
not getting satisfied then all of a
sudden she's like hang on a minute
what's this and you know and then the
marriage breaks up so I reckon it but it
is actually a factor and I think she's
not getting satisfied sexually they make
it too strategic so in her head she's
like all right let's do it I'm gonna
have have sex once a week you know I
mean like I'm not really built like that
as a man like sometimes the breeze might
blow and I'm like you know I'm active
now she's like no we really did it do it
so it's like I've got into the routine
of getting it once a week so it's like
it gets becomes more of a routine for me
as opposed to that yeah but that's the
problem with cohabiting though isn't it
just once a week
[Laughter]
it probably is
because again it's all about Fields
isn't it so that's why Viagra is like
that's why you get into a relationship
in the foreign
would you stick out a sexless marriage
for your children
yeah
I mean no this is not the ties maybe I
don't know there's yes or no yeah you
would check it out yeah yeah
I mean I have three others but you would
stick out cheating no
is it a cyclist of marriage worse than
cheetah at least you're good
Pidgey would have stuck out the cheating
well yeah it would have been harder to
for me to just be like okay we're not
doing this anymore okay okay
is that how you said it
huh
a sexist marriage but then you're going
to be frustrated all the time then
you'll start projecting that stress and
that frustration on people
I don't know oh no no no you wouldn't
stick it out
for the kids or wait till the kids are
older oh but uh so you got a
five-year-old
foreign
you can do Tantra there's so many other
ways that you can penetration is like
probably the least element of a woman's
sideboard
I think it's dependent on the reasons
why you know like if it's due to like a
to like medical issue or like busyness
or something like that I feel like
that's workable but if it's due to like
a complete lack in like attraction for
your partner and I don't really think
that's
you know
okay so so no
it depends okay okay so let's say he
just has a low sex drive now
a low sex drive I mean yeah I would say
I would just stick it out yeah okay what
about you would you stick it out of Mary
yeah of course
I'll stick it out you'd stick it out
yeah it depends on Long photo
[Music]
I found out that
if I had the most interesting stat I
want to pull it up
um
foreign
the sexless marriage is very different
by age so it's like
um of of people married over
of people married over 70 54 are sexless
so if you make it to 70 you probably
have first excellence and then it's like
60 to 90 is 38 and then 50 to 59 is 22
percent
and married people 40 to 49 8 so it's
like it's like very much dependent on
age yeah yeah but isn't that how it's
going to go though because like as you
get older it becomes more of a
companionship yeah and you know yeah I
get probably
also your body is less yeah
I've also heard that like nursing homes
have the worst STD rates yeah
because you're putting a bunch of people
in a home that what else have you got to
do
and then flip the bean
wow flick the bean
No One's Gonna worry about getting
pregnant as well so that's why they
don't strap up
true
strap up
assistant yeah yeah what do they do in
those in those homes I'm sorry
apparently they have lots
have sex and get a CDs
but where did they get when I can't
remember
Joe Biden do you reckon he's if you're
not still having it
I don't think what's the statistical
probability I've never thought of that
question and I don't want it it's 50 50
apparently because what is he like 70
yeah he looks about nice I don't think
he's awake enough at a time
like AE no no he's 70 something I think
yeah how old is Trump
1970s as well
Joe Budden is older than Trump yeah yeah
so sleepy Joe
yeah sleepy joke is active though
do you guys think that the fact that 50
of women are projected to be single and
childless reflects the quality of the
men or the quality of the women the
quality of the women
because
men obviously hold the access to
relationships so at the end of the day
like if it's turning out that 50 of us
are going to be
single and childless by I think it's
like
that 20 20 30. yeah
um
well that obviously says that we're not
doing something right because that is
scary that's so sad isn't that crazy
that's 50 of us so depressed not me yeah
50 of us in the room will be single and
childless by 2030.
the cold world out there so much so that
like big banks are investing in cat food
box wine like all the things that come
with single women I'm gonna invest
uh what do you think is it the quality
of the matter the quality of the women I
think the quality of choices
of the women
okay expand on that
um
well even my choice to
be a single parent you know if
technically I could be a single lady
with cats so I'll still be buying cat
food online and drinking wine I might
have kids with me but I mean
um I think that young women need to make
better choices 100 logical choices and
actually just think ahead like you were
saying earlier like the quick
gratification like
I never used to like think
further than what I needed in that
moment so it's like if and how I
communicate with my daughter now is very
different to how my mum communicated
with me so I think just choices because
your choices that you make now are going
to affect your life for the rest of your
life well when you're young what would
you do differently if you could go back
to 16.
um
I wouldn't have my children I wouldn't
have had my daughter at 16 100 because
it wasn't the best choice for her it
wasn't the best choice because I made
that choice for myself I was like I'm
gonna be a mum to this little girl
um and with my son
I wouldn't have been with his dad the
fourth or fifth time he cheated on me so
yeah I would have made better choices
because I was in a very cycle like oh
he'll stop eventually and so yeah I
would have made better choices over the
partners I was choosing not necessarily
like not have my children but just with
better Partners what would you have done
differently in the relationships not
been a complete psychopath
no just that yeah I was yeah I was uh
not the easiest of Partners to be with
and so I yeah I would have left because
the more I stayed with my son's dad the
more angry I got the more resentful I
got and so we were just arguing all the
time he like he could breathe he's just
his breathing annoyed me at one point
because I just resented him so much but
it was my choice to say that so if I did
and chosen not to stay there then I
wouldn't have yeah
I'm married did you have something you
want to say because you just grunting
over there
it's very like um
weird for me to speak because it
obviously is it's very real isn't it
well yeah it's my life exactly and you
know like sometimes when people say like
I wouldn't change a thing because of how
things are right now
so is it are you saying that you're not
in the situation you want to be in now
because not my children are not in the
situation that is the best for them
because my both of my children are a
statistical disadvantage I know that now
yeah but forget about statistical
disadvantage because you're like okay
say for example you're more statistical
advantages to go to jail if if you're
from a single parent family we know this
right all this other statistics but I'm
saying that doesn't necessarily mean
that your child has to go to jail no I'm
not saying it does but that she's saying
go back
and right do it differently and so of
course if I know that you know what
being a single parent isn't the best
idea for my daughter who doesn't has
never had a father in her life at all
because he told me to either have an
abortion or stay with him and so I chose
my baby over him and so in hindsight of
course I would want my daughter to get
both parents there loving her equally
like of course why wouldn't I want that
for my daughter I want her to be whole
and not feel like she somehow isn't
because her father doesn't want her
so like of course I would choose that
for her so are you saying that you're
incapable of finding someone that would
look after your daughter
she's 19 she's an adult so then were you
like what do you need to rewind the
world for like because if you asked me
the question no I'm saying in terms okay
I'm not rewinding it if someone asks a
question if someone asks me yeah if
someone asks me if I could go back in
time would I not do something that would
that would affect the situation that I'm
in right now if I say that I would
regret it that means obviously what I'm
going through now
I want to change no I want my children
not me because what about you though
then
so he's out he's asking if um you would
change it because you're not happy with
the situation you're in now not for me
personally because I'm I love both of my
children like the the situation that I'm
in with my children I would never change
it without a child without but for my
children if I could go back and make
better choices 100 what about you she
said she's trying to say she doesn't
regret her kids because she loves her
kids yeah yeah but what about you though
well of course for me it would be easier
if I was in a two-parent household as
well of course making better choices as
I was younger choosing to not be a
parent at 16 and having to live on my
own at 60. of course that would have
been a better decision to not do it like
who wants to be 16 while all your
friends are going off going out make
like having relationships I was at home
on my own with a little girl about
having to work out what to do with it
because I was 16 I didn't know what I
was doing with myself so of course like
there's no 16 year old that I would say
yeah this will be a great idea to make
this life-changing decision that's also
going to hurt the child and
like well I could say I could say on the
other hand then now you're 35 you're
still pretty young and your children are
old enough to do their own thing so now
you you could you pretty much got your
whole rest of life to yourself whereas
if if someone has better together but
sometimes you never if I had chosen a
better partner it's even if even if I'd
had a child at 16 but I had chosen a
partner that wanted a child with me and
wanted to have a baby and we was brought
that child up together that would have
been a better choice it was still my
choice he said I don't want this kid I'm
not have adult on it I'm never gonna and
he stuck to his word and he's never had
anything to do with my daughter so that
was my choice so I'm taking
accountability for my choices because we
create try my I've created a trauma in
my daughter the moment I chose for her
to have an absent father and so I mean
for anybody to say I don't want to
change that for me would be I'm like why
why wouldn't you want to change it was
16 though I mean come on I mean that's
like a child isn't it I was a child
even looking back I'm like like when my
daughter is 19 now and I can't even
imagine her holding a bit I was in yeah
I was in a rack actually by that point
so I was in Iraq and I had a three like
a three-year-old child what's a wreck
sometimes you never know of life like
with these two kids you never know
what's gonna happen like what if like in
five years one because you know my
children like like this genius and they
have like this they are amazing yeah
just because I had a good outcome it's
an anomaly yeah like just because it had
a good outcome it didn't mean it didn't
affect them growing up um
therapy for my daughter the amount of
presence that I have to have especially
because then I went in the military as
well so I double whammied it and like
make I have like because leaving a child
at one years old to go off to the
military obviously isn't great either
and and so
it doesn't matter how they turn out the
the journey to get to the end of it is
still a lot harder for my daughter than
it would be if she had I'm sure if it
used to having your father there they
when you've got a problem or a boy's
pissed you off you can call your dad my
dad doesn't have that she has to have my
[__] advice I'm like my brothers
[Music]
um it's some uh I mean I I knew my dad
and I was with my dad and that and I
didn't have that kind of relationship
with him but you're a boy it's different
for you as well if you say so I mean I
wanted a relationship that was a bit
deeper than it was I had both my
brothers say that about my dad they wish
they had a deeper relationship I wish um
anyways passed away man okay
it's too late but that's my point to
absence even in that there was part
elements of for you that you needed more
of my daughter doesn't have any of so
that I wish she can never like it's not
gonna ever happen so it's still a
element of pain that she has to
deal with and not because of her but
because of me all right let me give you
some new ones so now that I've I know
what a dad is like because I've grew up
with a dad in the household now I am the
image of my dad because I that's what I
saw as opposed to I didn't have an image
so I wouldn't know what to um base my
cell phone because as a dad you'd be
very
um
instrumental or very you imprint I
wouldn't say an exact copy but a lot of
kids become a lot of men become like
their dads and blueprint yeah but at the
same time it's then isn't that even more
a reason to like if my son didn't have
his father and I'm if anyone ever got
speeches I'm like on it I'm like
militant about how much time and even if
Ethan's trying to chat back I don't
argue with my son my son's dad has to
deal with the conflict in that situation
um but imagine if he didn't have that
there he is eventually going to seek
that out outside of my house and it
might not be a good blueprint that he
then starts to emulate
yeah
what do you think about let me repeat
the question
um about women being single and
childless by 20 30 50 of women are
projected to be single and childless
do you think that's the does that speak
to the quality of the women or the
quality of the men
is that to me no no you won't get
I think
I remember there was this class in
secondary school it was called life
skills okay
and we would touch this topic and um
they were just uh they taught us about
um what do they call it oh my God as
soon as I want to talk about having a
dating coach he just walks out the room
how I want it like having like um like a
coach for your marriage or your
relationships
um or even a dating coach like just
enlightening you and making you more
aware
but to say
like either one of um like female or
male like 50 of them being childless and
single I think it's about education just
educating yourself about what a healthy
relationship is how would you educate
yourself so if you're a Naomi situation
where she has never seen a functioning
relationship how would she do that
um you go to uh what do they call it's
like a mentor like a relationship Mentor
or like um a life coach at 16. yeah you
can get a life coach do life coaches
typically
are they typically married happy with a
family and kids
sometimes not typically they're
typically like 50 year old women who've
been divorced it'll be means
you're not taking dating advice from
them did you know there's an influencer
her name is oh can I say her name yeah I
might as well her name is Bianca Taylor
She's a life coach and personal trainer
and her boyfriend now fiance cheated on
her twice and she stuck it through
I mean if they saw
um a a I'm not a life coach like a
marriage like a relationship coach and
they worked through it but I feel like
okay they're Outsourcing families like
you're supposed to be able to go to your
parents and your grandparents and your
great-grandparents to get wisdom about
relationships and now it's like all the
things that you're supposed to do with
your family they Outsource yeah so now
you're speaking to a stranger that
doesn't have your best interest at heart
and you know in Naomi's situation what
else is she supposed to do it might be a
good option you know I mean at six times
I had therapy for it was damn expensive
but 60 pound a week so that she had a
good not just anything a good therapist
that was gonna be able to give her that
Mother like grandmotherly like advice
from a married woman oh she was married
yeah
but it's like it's like even therapists
like you're supposed to tell your
problems to your family your siblings
your cousins not strangers that don't
have your best interests at heart I I
think anyways but it's like in a modern
society it's like we're Outsourcing all
the stuff you used to do together and
because there's no emphasis on family
there's no value in family anymore and
women used to come together as well in
communities
and they used to actually want you to
win because they were married and happy
with their husbands but now it's like
you get older single women yeah telling
you they're wrong so like I see older
single women telling I had a oh my gosh
I had a girl on my show last week and I
asked her like would you encourage your
daughters to wait till they're married
when when when when if you're a virgin
on your wedding night you have an 80
chance of a happy marriage wouldn't that
be good for you and she couldn't even
this is her daughter no and it's like
this is the culture we have it's like we
don't even encourage Purity in our youth
anymore
um can I ask us a question about that
stat does that is that just straight
people or could that include like the
the colorfuls oh no it does straight so
that's only straight people yeah so
there's a couple different studies so
some of them will say 70 Chance some
will say so it's not specifically 80 the
most drastic one it goes 80 chance when
you have when you're a virgin on your
wedding night and then it drops to 50
chance when you have a two partners and
when you get to five you're down to 25
to 20 chance of a happy marriage really
solo yeah it what oh wait I was talking
about obviously
which one you know when you said that 50
of of people would be childless and
single
possibility women
it's just women so I'm saying is that is
that stat just for straight people
because if if if I'm if I'm not sure
I think it probably counts lesbian women
too let me 20 30. because they're not
gonna have any kids already who you'd be
surprised they've been adopting uh you
can have IVF and get donors like you
there's ways of lesbian couples having
babies
I'll get it wrong by like five percent
it's estimated that 45 of women aged 25
to 45 will be single by 2030 according
to a study by Morgan Stanley with the
women that with the modern dating Market
nearly half of women in their
childbearing years will be without a
male counterpart there's a few reasons
for this prediction one women aren't
getting married young anymore we have so
many other options for what to do with
our lives that getting married is no
longer the default option we're focusing
on our careers going to grad school
traveling our friends and extended
Social Circles circles and taking time
to find the right guy two we aren't
having babies like we used to with more
options for birth control than ever and
somewhat reliable treatments for
infertility the pressure to have kids
within a certain time frame just isn't
there anymore with the pressure gone
so is the urgency to get married for the
sake sake of starting a family so many
so many women are single that is
unmarried and will remain that way for
the foreseeable future
yeah because yeah
I understand you I was going to say that
most young people under the age of I
think I think they said it was 18 or 20
21 I think it was but they said that 40
of them identify as colorful so we
already know that it's going to be low
child rate anyway in a sense 40 of kids
under 18. under 21 identify as colorful
yeah what does that mean colorful
LGBT oh
all of that fun stuff yeah
I mean
why I thought you were lying it's I'm
done being serious shut up is that
underwater under 21. did you say hold on
I think it was that okay nearly 40 of us
gen Z's 30 percent
of young Christians identify as
lgbtq poll says 30 of Millennials
identify identify as lgbtq according to
soon soon to be release study that is
based on the scientific polling data
among Christians the number was lower
but only slightly with just 30 percent
of millennial Christians identifying as
lgbtq
this proportion of the population that
describes itself as gay has varied over
the years from 10 based on Research by
Alfred Kinsley and widely promoted by
the national gay task force in 1977 to
less than six percent in a recent Gallup
poll the pollster who worked the new
study attributes the unusually high
number he found to Social and news media
coverage that make it safe and cool for
Young Americans to identify as algae btq
whether or not it represents their
sexual orientation
is that so is that like bisexual
resistance bisexual like still going
throughout the people oh
so I mean yeah okay 40 I think it's
still a high number like do you know I
mean that's why it would be a little
birth rate you know I mean yeah well I
mean because you but you can still a
mold other people I reckon a lot of
those people will want to have kids
you've got money
somebody's got money to have IVF then
you can still have they can still have
kids yeah yeah and like it's probably
easier no wrong but wrong wrong what to
have hold on I'm gonna find these
numbers
now I mean it depends on your age for
IVF but I'm trying to find this it's
okay
um I just looked up the failure rates
for IVF 61.1 percent in woman under 34
73.7 percent in women 35 to 38
86.2 percent in women
um 39 to 42 and 94.4 in women over 43 so
if you're under 34 you still are more
likely that IVF will not work yeah it'll
work than it is to work
wow only 25 chance if you're 35 to 38.
crazy
but then again the people that that's
under 25 that's trying to get IVF is
probably because they can't get kids
well because they're a lesbian couple
but yeah
they're missing a key element but why do
you why do you think they push IVF as an
option if it doesn't seem like a very
good one accordingly because it makes
the money I mean well everyone is being
coupled that's kind of like unless
you're gonna step out but I don't
understand it gives you hope no it was
because he was saying oh that the
colorful I don't know I'm now copying
myself LGBT community won't have
children I'm like well they can't it's
still a possibility because they can
have IVF why do you guys think they push
that
I think they're doing it so you have
like um not hope but like it's okay
because you always got IVF like it's all
right to do this because you've got IVF
like in a sense where you know I'm
saying they give you like a backup like
to prolong having children exactly yeah
yeah I agree I think they they try and
give you all these options and it's like
it's the same argument with
um like the whole being a a single
parent and this whole argument of like
oh I don't need a man because I can I
can still have a baby like without a man
I can get sperm don't I can I can adopt
I'm actually adopted so like I know
quite a lot about it you can't adopt if
you're a single parent they won't give a
child to a single parent because it's
not good for them I mean my aunt had
that three with um and she was a single
parent I have two children in a late
District I don't know how but she had
them and then my now my cousin has to
Foster them because
um my aunt died but that is a
possibility it happened the social
services she adopted to a single one
she's always been single because she was
um they all have quite extensive special
needs and she was quite
um School my uncle yeah my uncle had
special needs so she she used to look
after him and then she when he went when
was no longer she was no longer able to
care for him she now she had three three
I think so I think what social services
would do they would look at each case
individually yeah the general rule is
that they won't they won't give a child
to a single parent home just because of
the statistics of single parent homes
like generally they try and place a
child with two parents but also like the
kind of kids that get adopted is really
low anyway so it's like people can say
Fosters yeah people could say oh I can
adopt I can adopt I can do this but at
the end of the day it's like is the
China child that you want gonna be up
for grabs and chances are no like the
most adopted type of child is
um a white female girl under the age of
one which is what I was and I'm one of
the lucky ones something like I think is
this probably really incorrect
statistics but I think it's something
like 50 000 kids get put into care each
year
um out of those that are adopted it's
like 2 000. last year it was just under
2000 and it's going down every single
year yeah because people don't want to
adopt because they don't want to adopt
the children that are older special
needs that's what I was gonna and boys
people don't want to adopt boys either
because there's stigma around boys who
are adopted rather than girls because
they see girls as more easy to mold so
people prefer picking a girl over a boy
this is all from data because when when
you go to adopt a child you have to fill
out a questionnaire of like what kind of
child you want like it's kind of like a
pick a baby program yeah yeah wait so
you pick what you're open to I don't
know you said 50 000. I think it's
something like that it could even be
higher but do you know what percent are
under the age of like two are really
small like it's majority of older
children that's what I thought because
my mom when she gave my brother up for
adoption she said it was really easy to
find a family
um but like from what I understand if
you give a baby up for adoption usually
they'll find a family but if they're
over a certain if there's a three I
think it gets harder and the problem is
women will try to keep babies that
they're not that they can't take care of
so then services will take them away so
then you have like a traumatized that's
what happened to me so I was taking I
was actually born in the oldest mental
institution in the world and I was taken
away because my mother couldn't cope and
where was that what's that bedlam
oh is that that's was that still going
it's now called Bethlehem Royal Hospital
Louis through actually did a documentary
on the mother and baby unit where I was
kept but um is that a South London isn't
it yeah it's South London it's near um
West Wickham beckenham kind of way oh
okay okay but yeah it's still going and
how old were you so I my mother was
sectioned when she was pregnant with me
and then I was actually taken away at I
think
the first incident was probably I was
like four weeks old then I was placed
into care when I was about a month and a
half and then I was in care until I was
eight nine months old and I was adopted
well I was placed with My adoptive
parents at nine months old but because
she wouldn't consent to the adoption it
had to go through the courts and I was
officially adopted in 2003 so I would
have been three and that's when my name
changed but I've actually been with my
adopted parents since I was nine months
old I see you got lucky I got extremely
lucky I'm so lucky because there's so
many kids out there who don't get the
chance and I'm really lucky in the sense
of like when I asked my parents like why
did you adopt me they don't say like oh
because we we wanted a kid all of this I
think that's a kind of a bad reason to
adopt it's like you'll then get that
child then feels like they have to
conform to like the idea of your perfect
child my dad always says to me we just
wanted to give someone a chance can I
say something they look like they did a
good job thank you very much they
they're amazing people yeah
yeah you know
um I've been on both sides of adoption
like where we've taken in kids and given
up kids an age I didn't realize how
important it was until I knew someone
um from a church I was in they adopted
two boys and one was under the age of
two and one was like five and the
five-year-old was like messed up for if
you can't even remember what happened
it's because of the the trauma that
happens and the neurological development
of the brain the first year of your life
is extremely important and up to the age
of three like anything that happens
before the age of three is kind of set
into the building blocks of who you are
and it can be really hard to unlearn
that and adopted children all have the
same attachment type it's you know the
body knows whether you get told you're
adopted or not the body knows that it's
been separated from something so you're
always going to have some kind of
distorted attachment style and that's
why you need to be placed with good
adopted parents that understand that
because adopted children are the hardest
children to parent because they're
confused what attachment started do you
say do you have that is it a specific
one or so it's it's not it's not one of
the three um bulby ones it's not
avoidant
um secure or the other one there's a
fourth one and that's adopted children
all right
um anxious avoidance is it a combination
but it's got a different name on that
one is it this one confused avoidance
it's something about being confused it's
it's it's something about like needing
to fill a void because you've had
something stripped so it's something
about like trying to to fill a void and
you get attached to things quite easily
even things like ideas like I'm a really
passionate person like yeah if I'm like
really into a film I'm really into that
film so yeah yeah it's things like that
it's just this kind of um I think it's
this kind of like desperateness within
like in in the child sense anyway
because the child is kind of desperate
for something to cling onto and it
depends as well if you've been through
multiple foster parents that messes you
up even more because you build your
primary attachment with your mother and
then your secondary attachment with your
father and obviously that then gets
broken so like with me for example I
didn't meet my biological father he
wasn't around my mother I'd obviously
built an attachment to hers with her for
a good month before I was straight from
her then I was placed in care so then I
built another attachment with the the
mother who looked after me in foster
care and then that was stripped and then
I was finally adopted so that's three
broken mother attachments and it's
really interesting because me and my
adopted dad are really close and
everyone says we're the exact same
person that's because I never met my
biological dad in foster care there was
no paternal figure around and then I was
placed with my adopted dad so the
relationship I got to form with him came
naturally where I was with my mother
growing up we conflicted a lot because
I can say this now as an adult because I
know now but as a child I didn't trust
her because I thought well you're going
to leave like the other two did yeah so
it's there's a whole bunch of stuff that
goes on there that when you're a kid you
have no idea like why any of this is
happening when you get older if you're
lucky enough and blessed as I was to
have parents who who can help you get
through things and support you through
therapy and things like that you can
figure out and you'll be all right but
and it's so interesting because the two
brothers that I knew the difference in
them was so crazy like the the younger
one he he's like a super talented
musician he's like the nicest guy at the
church like he was so involved and the
other one like stole money from the
church he like was involved in all these
crimes his family like put him in the
military because they just didn't know
what to do like it's so crazy and it's
just and neither of them remember
anything yeah but one was just five and
one was just I don't know one two so
it's I know it's yeah I mean I can't
remember like I don't remember anything
I was under the age of one I haven't
yeah I have no recollection but there
are it is really interesting because
there are things that you do
that you can trigger with things like
therapy to remember so I've always had a
really bad fear of needles and I never
knew why I've I've got tattoos I've got
piercings it's not normal needles it's
specifically medical needles and I never
knew why until in therapy I actually
discovered as a kid I used to say to my
parents I feel like I saw my birth
mother get um sedated I always used to
say I think that's why I'm scared of
needles because I maybe I saw something
like that or maybe when I was in her
womb something like that and obviously
there was no way I could have possibly
known until I when I got older I met
someone who was there when I was in the
no mental institution and I did as a
baby I saw her get sedated a bunch of
times so I knew I knew my whole life as
a child I knew that I saw that but then
people will say well how could you know
you're under the age of one but I didn't
know that's unbelievable the Mind
remembers everything you just have to
dig it out do you have any um can I ask
do you have any
um contact with your your mother now no
I can't she's dangerous and my
biological Father's Side
um aren't the friendliest of people not
very accepting but
I'm so lucky like my adopted family is
great like I can't complain
now the crazy thing that happened in our
family was my one brother I didn't meet
till I was 22. so my mom got pregnant
when she was 17. same mom and dad but
they were just young and I didn't when I
met him when he was 22. he was more
similar to my family than the the
adopted Kevin granted the adopted kids
were teenagers but I mean still they
spent more time with our family than
than he did yeah and literally he was 30
like one when we met him and he walked
like my brother he studied economics in
school I studied economics at school his
family was in like a two kids there
there was two kids and they never left
the like small town they were from and
he owned a sailboat like literally his
brother never left the town his parents
never like they just didn't like to
travel didn't like to do anything
adventurous obviously I'm in London we
travel in life yeah so it was so crazy
because it was like we met we met him
and he's just like our family and then
we had zero contact yeah genetics
genetics so much nature so much yeah and
I used to I used to think it was all
nurture because because of single
motherhood stats so I would think well
if these are the outcomes when they're
in these positions like it has to be
much worse or it has to be more nurture
until no nature yeah
genetics that like that you have
mutations in yeah what trauma can create
they say up until conception
um from a man in Jacqueline from a woman
like any trauma that your grandmother
would have had because obviously your
mother was in your womb and you were
also it's all coded in your DNA it's all
coded in your DNA yeah yeah oh yeah man
yeah so well you don't have to believe
in it
that's what I say General generation
it almost went into my brain and stayed
there that just went out one ear went
out the other one trying to say the
child the grandchild
is genetically so it might all have a we
have all of our eggs so when I was
pregnant with my daughter when my mum
was pregnant with me yeah
now when my grandmother was pregnant
with my mum
I was inside of my mum when I was inside
of her tummy so anytime also it doesn't
mean trauma is in the the when we say
trauma we don't mean situational trauma
of things like Memories so when we say
that trauma is encoded in the DNA we
mean the product of that trauma so for
example trauma is really highly linked
to autoimmune disorders because the body
stores stress when you're stressed when
you're going through some kind of trauma
that exerts stress on the body you
release loads of cortisol and that
cortisol affects how your organs work it
affects your fight or flight response
things like that so when we say that the
trauma is encoded in the DNA we don't
mean oh you remember something that
happened to your grandma in the 1920s we
mean the product of that trauma is
embedded in the DNA so you then might
have health issues that are linked to
that trauma the body remembers
everything even if the mind doesn't I
don't agree with that just like just
like how I don't agree with that that um
cancer is hereditary I don't believe it
we all have um dharmon cancer cells like
every
um I think I think a lot of cancer is
caused from parasites yeah but that
means that garment cells are there no I
don't know I'm not a cancer in terms of
what you said in terms I did not know
that that your eggs are into you when
you're born what do you mean yeah you
have your eggs yeah all your eggs that's
how our egg count as we get older that's
how we hit a wall and men don't because
your sperms like produced hours
you're saying you're born with eggs in
you yeah well where else do they come
from
generational questions
you produce I don't know how do I
produce it and you don't produce things
that's how women that's how we have a
set amount of eggs
after you're born no before you're born
where do you think they come from right
after you're born
this is all happening
are women born with eggs in them
oh my
God like before they're born yeah
oh my head hurts
like I know there's someone Smart in a
Super Chat that would donate 100 to find
tonight current knowledge indicates that
females are born with their entire life
time supply of gametes at Birth the
normal female ovary contains one to two
million eggs see look I need to learn
something every day but you didn't want
to believe it you're full of two million
eggs God damn I did not know that that's
a lot but this thing about generational
trauma this thing about trauma that gets
passed down though that's that's really
interesting but you're also you're
saying it's not true so what about when
I say trauma
she's the only girl on my show that said
trauma and it hasn't triggered me yeah
went into a scientific element of it and
explained what she meant well because
that just wouldn't mind his boyfriend
cheated on it so I've got trauma
um
yeah so wait so okay are you still stuff
on the eggs
that helps a different kind of worms
that opens a different kind of worms
then because if if you're born with the
eggs yeah and you're out doing your
thing isn't that gonna affect your great
great grandchildren what do you mean
it's not until you're pregnant that like
obviously because yeah
what what any anything actually
environmental any any anything that you
do whilst you're
alive yes it will affect your body so
you mean yeah hold on to stress yeah oh
yes
well that affects you anyway you
shouldn't be doing that anyway just for
your own mental health and Sanity so if
you're you're only friends and stuff and
then your eggs are there watching and
then
your eggs are affected like so it's not
just you in it and for men up until open
like even for you guys if you're smoking
that can cause the harm in your sperm
when the conception happens anything you
do up until ejaculation will affect your
child as well so same same
yeah why do you guys think that um
we just need to be more educated within
the relationship and more like life
skills we talked about Outsourcing
families yeah okay so you're next why do
you think that half of women will be
single and childless
um I think that that is because women
have you know more
I feel like we're at more of a position
now to not rely on men as much which I
don't necessarily think is a bad thing
um
so yeah I don't think like I don't think
that statistic is
inherently negative if anything I think
it's positive because I think it thinks
I think it shows that people are putting
more thought into having children rather
than just having children because you
know it's what we should do they're
having children because
you know they have the right situation
for the child would you say that when
women get the option to
would you say that when women
um
make money then they don't they they
don't need men anymore and they don't
want men
no I I wouldn't say that I think women
women it just sounds like what you were
saying a little bit
um no I think they weren't necessarily
settle for some for a situation that
doesn't isn't beneficial or doesn't
bring happiness to them but I don't
think when women get money they just
don't seek men anymore you think it's a
good thing that we don't have as many
kids
yeah I do because I think people what is
your favorite it's not worked in China
because I think people can get messed up
by not having parents that you know are
necessarily ready to have children I
agree with you yeah
but you don't think
because I'm just thinking you think most
women will be happy at 55.60 with no
kids no Legacy no husband I think if you
need kids and a husband to have any sort
of Happiness within you then I have
friends that 100 they're older than me
women that they are sad that they don't
have a partner and they don't have like
for me I'm never lonely like so I when
people say oh What's it gonna be like
when you're I'm like I don't know
because I've never been on my own so
like I'm so but I can imagine like if
you're 55 60 and you have nobody what
what about them times when you're sick
who's gonna come I'm gonna help you uh
who's gonna like when you fall down the
stairs because your hips aren't doing
the thing anymore like who's gonna who's
gonna be there you might be lying in the
house and nobody knows you're dead yeah
what does Christmas look like what do
you spend Christmas with you and a
sparkler but I don't know how these
women will be tick-tocking Christmas
no I'm sorry sorry keep going keep going
no I don't think having a man is
necessarily the only way that you can
avoid loneliness because I think a woman
as well yeah but just a partner in
general I think there are other
relationships that you can make once you
get older and everyone else starts to
get there like your friends start to get
married off because that's what tends to
happen the guys that would be on cycle
like for these women where they'd have
like the quick gratification they then
start to get married off then then who
because your friends that are married
are not gonna just turn up at your house
on Christmas Day I think the
conversation is that a lot of women are
not doing that anymore so if a lot of
women aren't doing that anymore you're
not going to be that only one that's not
married without children you know so how
did you know how did you notice you lot
thing and it's not our thing because it
takes two to tangle so we could be like
now fire by new look we're not doing it
that's why I asked why you think that is
well because men will sleep with
anything no
um
having sex anymore like I'm pretty sure
majority of Men In My Generation like
aren't even having sex exactly it's wild
because they're scared because they
don't want to have sex and then get me
too wait what no no no no they're also a
scared to approach
es
have you ever heard that stat that one
in three men under 30 are either virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year yeah
no I know you
you've been on the show too many times
have you have you heard that's that
um is that surprising to you
that can you repeat it please one out of
three men are either virgins or haven't
had sex in the past year
does that surprise me
um not necessarily
that doesn't surprise me I would say a
lot of people that I know aren't
necessarily like I feel like on podcasts
like this people like to you know
especially when we're talking about
marriage and men cheating and stuff like
that like we get this idea that men just
don't know how to control themselves or
are less able to control themselves than
women and I don't necessarily well the
problem is as women were sharing men
because it's a smaller and smaller
percentage of men that are having sex
and women are still having sex at
similar rates I mean it's a little bit
more but not not enough but it's
significant so it's it's
all the women are sleeping with the same
men basically
and especially as they get older like
what you think those single women aren't
sleeping with anyone we just one big
polygamous polyamorous without even and
so that's why it's funny when we talk
about like would you be okay with
sharing a guy most girls say no but we
do yeah is that surprising to you or no
surprising that women share men no no
she's like
I do think that you know it's not
necessarily like I said I don't
necessarily think it's a bad thing I
think it's just more of a communication
thing like I think if you're sleeping
with someone and they don't mention the
fact that they're you know seeing other
people sleeping with other people
because they know that you won't be okay
with it I don't think that that's right
or the correct thing to do can I can I
interject it's not necessarily that I'm
cheating on you it might just be that
you're two weeks or someone else's two
weeks and then another two weeks and
then like they like I've seen I've seen
men
that we're talking about now
in this category of men I see how they
operate and I know why the stat is like
the way it is so basically
um a really pretty girl would see this
really handsome guy and she's fixated
with him she'll ignore all the warning
signs she'll ignore everything she will
think this is the right man for me
they'll sleep together they'll see each
other for a little bit and then they
break off and then that another girl
would do the same process go through
that same thing and then do that same
thing again and then do that same thing
again same thing again again again again
and again and by the time he's been
through like 12 girls
that one guy that on the other side
that's like you know what I'm not gonna
stoop down to that level or I'm not
gonna take her
um I'm not gonna take an not serious how
would I say that I'm exclusive yeah yeah
that's not going to take exclusive he's
he's not getting nothing
not necessarily that he might be not
handsome yeah he's handsome or it's just
that extra like umph at the start when
the girl's like yeah I like him I'm
breaking all my rules I'm going with him
it's like even the the trainer she was
talking about how many how many girls
was he sleeping with seven you said at
the gym oh no B the whole class and
usually a cloth will be like 30 Max and
majority of the old they'll be like one
or two men in there but it'll be like
all the women and for him he he
convinced himself look this is how you
this is how you keep your classes
popular but he didn't want to admit to
the fact that he had a sex addiction he
was hoeing himself out for his numbers
well yeah but if he's if he's having sex
with 30 chicks that means there's 30
guys that aren't having sex with those
girls oh no they were married they were
all married well is that a picture you
need to get that guy on the show he
sounds like yeah
he got his number
oh no no no no no no
I'll keep on away from the women on the
show no no he would stalk me so I don't
I don't wanna
um Troy what do you why do you think
women are going to be single and
childless well I think it's likely that
they are timing themselves out of uh
contention unfortunately I think it's
everything that people have mentioned
already you know that there is this
sense that the party can just carry on
for as long as as long as they want and
obviously there's all these other
demands of you know career and boss babe
and all that kind of stuff so I think
that that's primarily why it is and also
as well uh just to touch on what we've
just said just now also because their
standards are very high so they're
looking for the Apex guy you know
they're looking for the you know the the
top one percent dude or whatever and
obviously not everyone is going to lock
down that guy you know
um most of them aren't and in waiting
for that guy because everyone's
expectations are raised so high because
of Instagram and you know all the rest
of it
then you know they eventually they time
themselves out because they didn't get
that that super hot dude at the top and
you know then it's like oh [__] it's too
late now so I think it's a combination
of those things
[Music]
Instagram will do it you know what I
mean yeah
yeah yeah you know Instagram's ruin
Humanity hasn't it yeah well it's it's
funny when we put in when we do the
delusion calculator it's like I don't
know have you guys seen the delusion
calculator
that's a thing oh maybe we'll do it
okay okay blessing can you pull up the
website what is it legal delusion
calculator
um and then answer the question then
he's gonna pull it up get me why do you
think women are going to be single and
childless pretty much for the reason
what we're getting a delusion calculator
what's the delusion calculator I've
already had to rank myself on here
um okay basically we're gonna put in
your requirements for a guy ah and we're
gonna decide how crazy you are
okay
um let's start let's start on this side
What's
um what what age range would you date
ah I would say
um 20 to
27.
how old would you date would you date a
married guy
would you date a married guy no okay
take out exclude married thank you
do you care about race
no no any race okay go down go down how
tall
seven foot
um
I would say five ten and above okay five
ten blessing thank you five ten uh
minimum I mean I get you it's all right
was it minimum income
would you date an obese guy
yeah really I don't really okay uh
minimum income I don't know because for
me because I'm 20 is like
a student so and then obviously not
really making any money okay so zero
okay 25. so you win Theta guide is 28.
but you date an obese 20 year old
it's hair choices the hair preferences
if he's funny and he treats you right
you never know so he's 20 he's broke and
he's he's a piece
it just depends you just take anything
at this point right she's delicious
because obviously I feel like because
I'm young obviously if I'm dating
someone that's 27 32.9 that's not bad
what did you put in for income blessing
oh you put so yeah so that that's
including the obese 20 year olds
but still 30 of them that's the highest
number we've gotten is this delusional
or not delusional down to earth period
like a Down to Earth good job good job
okay next
um 30.
oh yeah you're 26.
it's uh
45.
hmm race
um
I don't mind I don't mind
anyways okay good anyways
oh Jesus not married do you have um do
you have do all your exes look the same
or do they look different they look
different okay so you I don't have a
little boxes say any but then their exes
all look the same and I'm just like
that's not you know what the girl that
my childhood sweetheart
we looked alike that's the most
creepiest thing
well I mean most people have types yeah
I don't think no no look I said look we
looked up would you would you date a
married guy would you side chick it up
try to try to steal it yeah she's like
yeah what okay okay
um I won't be inviting you to my house
wait what your contradiction yeah
in another name and then you
you because you can legally be married
but the relationship you can be
separated in your in the middle of a
divorce isn't it and that that happens a
lot yeah nice get out nice out
what if he's happily married you trying
to oh no no okay just if he's in the
middle of it yeah we'll keep we'll keep
it minimum height
um six four
he has to be sure
five foot eleven is minimum
cappers bro okay out for Omega cafes bro
minimum no five foot ten guys getting no
play out here minimum income
um 100k
I left my lesson with my childhood
sweetheart about lending what he's off
okay a hundreds
um when you say 100K you mean in um in
pounds so put like a hundred and like
20K
yeah this is yeah okay it's similar
though
um obese
I'm gonna sound so shallow no okay so
he's got to make 120k not be obese but
could be married
[Laughter]
don't click again what percent of guys
do you think make over 100k
I would say in the five percent okay
let's let's go down
no
wow
so I have a question do you think you're
in the top 1.9 percent of women
no
so is it delusional to ask for the top
1.9 percent of men
wait wait ask the question again well do
you think you're in the top one percent
of women one point or two percent well
so my income 100 women you're the top
two
with your income yeah oh I feel so
bratty saying it but yeah but you know
income doesn't matter I don't care about
your income yeah
you still think top two percent
were you were you raised to be a wife
no
so how would you be in the top two
percent if you weren't raised to be a
wife
wing it
like top two percent of what looks like
what are you top two percent companion
she bought the other bloke a car yeah
that's why I'm a little I'm a bit picky
um
uh two percent I was up I mean two
percent's a lot you know I'm not I'm not
trying to insult you two percent's just
a lot like out of a hundred women top
two
no but could you can you see how your
one experience with your ex could um
Ulta how you see other men
oh 100 so yeah so if he was to rack up
the amount of men the amount of problems
would increase
so it's not necessarily that manner like
yo I don't want her because she's been
with 40 men but she comes with 40 men
different problems right you know I mean
different issues from 40 men
what's wrong with being really really
picky though
um
I'll just have like loads of love the
problem with being picky is that not not
all humans are not no human's perfect
yeah and um relationships about building
so a lot of time I would meet girls and
then literally like two months after I'm
like you know what she's actually
alright and I'm like maybe I should have
um
sought to find out a bit more about her
as opposed to the Shadow level or some
people don't give you everything they
have at the start
you know so when you first you're you're
judging someone on their first
um
I think a lot of girls do this they
judge them on the first appearance
and that might not necessarily be the
man that you're actually going for
because then again a man has to be a
certain way in order to come to you
anyway
forget what you're saying but I don't
want to be put in a position where I'm
like that football player you know I
mean that's why I'd rather be picky or
just be single and what about what but
what about him though did you see what
his ex-wife well soon to be ex-wife well
you can just get prenup I mean this
place and surely if you're marrying them
like at that point women are more likely
to test your money what would be a worse
outcome for you no no children or no no
money
so if you're 60
what would be what would be a worse
outcome I would say no money simply
because with money you can
um
give uh that money to kids in foster
homes you can build orphanages you can
create opportunities for other people is
that what you do with your money
um well I create opportunities for young
people for jobs in the entertainment
industry so yeah that's what I do
but yeah I'm just a very picky person
very picky picky picky are you camping
I'm actually very picky
all right let's get State your time
State your time State attack give us the
list man give us the list she just she
just did no the propolis that's that's
like cat Bagless you know what for me
have you ever dated a guy that makes
that amount of money yeah I'm the guy
that I'm seeing now well actually he's
your boyfriend
but it's just like if I we wanted to be
exclusive I would have to convert My
Religion so that's why I'm taking my
time
okay but it's still a situationship yeah
but it's bad choice not his choice if it
was his choice they would be together oh
no look he's choosing not to be with him
so we're working it out because I don't
want to be in like a you know get
married and have kids to someone because
they wanna they want me to convert to
their religion like I should be able to
just what relations
oh no we're closing the situation
um
what religion are you I'm not a
religiously not Muslim no no no muslim
man doesn't need to marry just a Muslim
woman you can marry a Jewish woman so
what like what would you need to convert
to then he might want her to convert
yeah
listen to what I'm saying to you I'm
saying a Muslim man according to Islam
does not need to just marry a Muslim
woman personally he wants to marry a
Muslim woman that's what she's saying
I think Mary is saying he's capping he's
capping yeah no basically he always
talks about marriage with me like he
wants to get married to me and have kids
but he says
obviously you have to convert to my
religion and I'm just like exactly you
see yeah but but this is like talk you
know this isn't you know when I say like
have you dated a guy that's over 100k
and it sounded like you were saying yes
and then I ask you more questions and
the real answer is no
because you're not dating him it's a
talking phase oh no like
yeah we've been seeing each other for
three four years but he wants to take
the next step
for three years three three four years
do you know what you should call his
bluff tell him that you're going to
convert see what he does she doesn't
need to convert it's called his blood
and he's not your boyfriend after three
four years he's not your boyfriend you
should have called him it's not a
situation about three four years
if he's not your boyfriend it's a
situation no we as women we put all
these stupid words where we call it
dating or like what happened no no no
it's different because when you're
dealing with a Muslim man like he
to bring a non-muslim person home
because obviously his family is very
traditional is he um is he sleeping with
you because a man in Islam shouldn't be
sleeping with you if he's if he's not
going to honor that and come to your
family first and speak to you and do all
of that surely that should have been
done first if he's having any intimate
relationship with you so for him to use
that as a reason for you him not
marrying you it's wild do you do you
know him
as friends
information do you need at this point to
know if you want to convert or don't
know you if you want to convert like you
you know him right you know his
character
you know what he's like
I'm sure you've looked into the Muslim
religion a little bit so it just it
sounds like this isn't gonna work out
like it sounds like you're not gonna
convert just if you've been three four
years to think about it yeah I don't
think you're converting or are you
crying it's one of those things like
we're trying to walk out like for him to
just like like accept
okay wait are you are you are you
non-believer then
no I grew up um a Hare Krishna it's not
religion it's a philosophy it's a way of
life a way of thinking right it makes
sense now it makes sense yeah oh what
Christian
Harry Christian
it's not a religion it's a way of
thinking it's a philosophy
stuff that's Buddhism no that's not
Buddhism
is he only seeing you or is he seeing
other people
I know he's only seeing me you sure
about that yes because at the beginning
we were both um open and then after I
think the two-year Mark then we start
being exclusive
he told you to be exclusive no we're
both exclusive no that's what I'm saying
like he told you to be exclusive
yes right yeah so but then your hits
you're a side piece until he gets
married to his Muslim thing
you're twisting this story
I'm giving you a man's perspective like
without all the fluff in between
basically
I mean
kind of agree I've got lots of Muslim
friends and they had their pieces that
weren't Muslim and then mum found a
beautiful Muslim wife and
the side piece would still be there and
some of them actually had children with
a side piece but she was not actually
ever a part of the family and still to
this day would never be a part oh no
like this guy he's
he's been office many times and the
women that have been offered to marry
him who are also Muslim their income is
more than his and he said no because he
wants like a love marriage but how old
are you again I'm 26. when would you
like to be married by 30.
do you feel like you're wasting time
with this guy because it's clear to me
it's clear you're not going to convert
yeah so wouldn't it be smarter to not
see him anymore basically well she's
you're hoping he's going to come around
to your way thank you you can't
basically
pretty much yeah but it's been three
years four years you're making them
choose between his God and his woman
he's not gonna do it
you were saying before you would trust
the person that you're with like what
don't you trust in him and his God like
like what is it because his family is
traditional but him he's not traditional
everyone for you converting for love
why is that going to be such a detriment
to you if you love him you trust him you
trust his lead and he's saying I want
you to be part of my religion and hold
God in such a Sacred Space with me why
is that a bad thing because it's not
what she believes is it goddess it's God
no she said she don't you don't choose
to believe something what what so who
chooses it for you you just if I told
you that when I went to the toilet 20
minutes ago I saw a Bible
I'm talking about her love for her
partner we're not just that also she was
saying no but you said out of love for
him she should choose to believe it I
didn't say choose to believe I said
because you said that does she not
believe in God you don't believe in God
that's my question you don't believe in
God do you believe different religion
it's the universe
do you go to the church or anything
uh that we don't have a church it's like
a more like a temple and we meditate
okay so oh so you actually are like a
practice I don't really understand what
you're talking about when you're saying
more where I'm being more conscious but
religion translates into Faith um Faith
but it's not a religion if you have a
faith of the universe right which has
just got a label God Universe whatever
you want to call it if you have that
true faith in that would if you love him
and he's not good it's just a stand-up
like Paul said it's either you choose
that and he's not gonna choose you
without that so it's that would you then
not choose that for him
because it's God it's not like he's
saying oh become a mass murderer with me
yeah yeah I understand that but the what
the complicated thing is
he's not traditional like he doesn't
really follow the religion okay it's his
family that follows the religion and he
respects his family so much that he's
just like
he's lying to you he doesn't he doesn't
he doesn't want to try to come he
doesn't want to come across to you like
he's the one that's telling you to do it
so he's going to give you excuse of
someone else that's the reason why you
have to do it but really and truly if he
wanted to he'll become Harry Christian
but he can't because he knows what in
his head what he what he's um what is
what he's aiming for do you get what I'm
trying to say to you that's why I say
he's kind of he's leading you like okay
I'm gone but he he doesn't follow the um
he's just a spiritual person okay
by birth rather than by his actual own
spiritual practice yeah yeah okay
and to be honest I would rather have
something like this than be single and
just having like seeing this person and
like my body count goes up so I'd rather
have something like stable and
consistent yeah but
it shouldn't be like oh you're either in
this situation or you have to go out and
304 it up I mean I mean I think what
people would say would be you would find
somebody else where maybe you're more
aligned in terms of your belief sir so
that you didn't have this problem
so do you follow your religion then like
it's not a religion it's a philosophy
it's a philosophy right so it's really
really Jean so do you follow your um
religious philosophy
I would say I'm more of a spiritual
person no no I mean in terms of like do
you practice it like you've you're able
like you say he doesn't really follow
his Islam but do you really follow your
it's your stuff
um no I would say I'm a spiritual person
exactly I wouldn't say it so I'm saying
if you're not really following your
thing
like anyway I
call this Bluff
though
[Music]
could this be the first just pearly
things uh marriage proposal yeah yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
it's 12 o'clock
all I'm saying how old is he
I think he's I think after four years
wait 35. all right I'm telling you you
literally have about I went into his
birthday
um July right you have literally two
months to to convert before his mom gets
on to him if you get me before his mom
and dad get something to him and says
listen you're going Pakistan bro oh my
God I can't believe I'm doing this you
don't have to no sorry I was like shut
up
so I call him yeah take a deep breath
and do it then what do I say I've
decided Let's Get Married listen what
what what is stopping us from getting
married
I'm not converted if that's the case it
doesn't no
be quiet then shh
I was disgusting I don't do this we'll
put it on speaker put on speaker
don't want his name
life-changing man I don't know I don't
know about this it's up to you I'm not
either way it's up to you okay pressure
no no it's up to you I think I remember
do it in private than public
okay
like I will I will call his bluff and
I'll say like I will convert and see
what he really says yeah but maybe not
publicly like privately yeah dude and
come back on the show and let us know I
will yeah I'll let you know you can do
it that way yeah um do you know who I
played for that happening like thank God
yeah you all thank God in like what do
you mean we want excitement out here
because I want her to get married and if
she does says that she'll convert and
then she does convert and then she gets
married then it's happy I don't want her
to get dumped because
also it's on a show listen you don't
really forget what she said someone did
that to me I'll be like you're invading
my friends forget what she said if
you're not Super Chat 500 pounds right
now for bless his motherboard will make
we'll make her do it
a thousand dollars guys I remembered
what my announcement was at the
beginning of the show
um next week we're having shows on
Monday and Tuesday and um Justin Waller
and sneaker are coming so
um okay I'm gonna Read Super chats
really quick
um guys make sure you like the video and
subscribe to the channel the like is the
most important metric that YouTube uses
to push out these streams I'm trying to
I lost the super chats okay here we are
okay
sorry G um she needs to drop him he's
not going to come around Lawrence
Bullock when you all talk about the
footballer you all neglect to mention
the soon to be ex-wife is a model and
actress is 1.7 million Instagram
follower sounds like an independent
woman to me Gus you want to get married
you have to change for the man you want
Mr
b693 girl you're just a side chick just
accept it says Brown SAS James Brown if
we join the third tier um do you follow
us forever
um you know
maybe not forever forever is a long time
you know what I mean for a while until I
forget where they banned me again
um Dion um no short guys no obese guys
but if you say no whales or Broke Girls
talk about double standards and capping
um Mr B93
um why women want to change a man to
leave them later a Mr B93 bro it's
called the wall for a reason Xavier
Johnson a bro is asleep I appreciate him
having a different opinion but he sounds
spiritually slow it's all connected fam
get ready for breakfast
um correlation is not causation but 40
percent were doomed Francisco our women
find it more painful to lose their phone
than their virginity
Dion C Pearl please get some heavy
hitting red pill guys on the panel
there's so much simping nowadays black
Moses the simping is strong on the panel
today hey yo remember that alert and
oriented Pearl fantasize yourself with a
post-modernist feminist philosophy
ideology and history to better
understand
adversaries Dr Stephen Hicks is a good
source Mr b69 it's so rare that we can't
believe it still exists Nestle hustle
big shout out to the panel in pearly the
channel is growing two million Subs
before 2024. Doug MPA beard game gang is
a super simp don't trip over your cape
Angelica after getting cheated on after
getting cheated on some people become
toxic and insecure the worst type of
partner so it's not always something you
can work through easily Mr B93 women
have a timer when they provide for the
house
um w why not oh I wrote that one zero
Fallout funny how people how they shame
men in the past now women want open poly
relationships don't want and don't want
to judge everything they shame men for
they are now doing it's all projection
Gus weak people use the word partner for
relationship Lawrence women talk about
cheating is interesting they blame men
as if he's at fault but they also blame
the man as if they're the ones that
cheated ladies do your mother submit to
your father's Gus in France it's illegal
to get a DNA test um clown world going
remote to passport downplaying your
lifestyle and job title will keep the
street Walkers away Gus hey can we play
as chess while everyone plays Checkers
going remote to passport Pearl can you
add
um
hakimi's full name to the title of the
video his name is going viral and men
need to be aware of that matter
um Let me refresh it just to make sure I
didn't miss any guys
um make sure you sign up for the Google
form too that should be in the chat um
mrb93 funny how men can see that a man
is lying to her Saint G she needs to
drop him oh he's not going to come
around her about that
uh we had two more delusion calculators
right and then we were done I thought
you forgot
we got two more two more then we'll
close out the show
yes what does that mean
um age
um 35 to 46 47 maybe 48. how old are you
again 36 okay
um
um yeah I I only really date black guys
are mixed okay black
there's no mixed option I know what the
hell
um go oh marry you guys no married
minimum height I'm five eight I'm five
eight so cap my X was five eight so I
mean I was with him for three and a half
years so that's not okay what royal
cappers how tall are you what just like
that just how tall are you just like
just like the eggs stand up stand up
stand up let me see this
um so basically you're just a pick me up
man you don't think shorter men deserve
women like I was five my ex was five
eight
um obese
um
probably not no I've not date up to now
I've not dated anyone minimum income
um 80.
70 80. all right was he five eight and
skinny or was he five eight and well
like big and like you said hi there was
no added no because it was now you know
what I mean she said no
no also she's validating what you're
saying no I mean like Bueno big like
punch pinch point two eight percent
where where
yeah well I mean yeah it's my my exes
were all of those things but
wait scroll down now
so you described your ex there
[Laughter]
have a type so yeah like I'm I'm not
going to pretend that I don't have a
time your ex caller man just that's cool
yeah would you ever budge on any of
those things 100 100 but that's just
like my preferences like obviously I
would nothing's like
Point concrete nothing I think I think
because you did the race I think that's
why it was so much smaller they're just
the type of guys that don't that I don't
get chatted by white guys
I'm not in that category
like I've seen white men shirts
[Music]
your turn
um
[Music]
I guess
20 to
everybody nice
not married
no thanks race doesn't bother me any
minimum height five eight not obese
minimum income doesn't matter
bro that's what I'm saying bro I'm not
gonna say it because it's like none of
these five eight guys are getting all
playroom my ex was five eight and
actually yeah I mean this is the second
highest well how old are you 22 Yeah so
I mean she did to student it's like yeah
I could oh yeah but you wouldn't you
wouldn't date a 33 year old with no job
no money yeah
because they're 20 with no job it's like
okay fair enough if they're 33 with no
job I mean it depends why like you know
this is something something like at
least like even if he's like a busker at
least he's got a passion
even at 20 even at 20 I'm sure even if
he's a student he'll they'll be doing
something my daughter is working I don't
know I think you should change it from
it like who you want to go out with to
who you don't want to sleep with because
you look all well and good to be like
yeah I'll date a five eight guys sounds
like it's the last resort kind of thing
as opposed to what I wrote
what would be the minimum yeah it's like
minimum obviously if I'm going to
attract six foot five
it's your ideal should be your size
because because this just seems like all
of your minimum standards that you
accept
minimum I accept a five eight man you
should be putting like your ideal
exactly because you'd be like oh I
really go for six foot free guys all the
time but you know what I'll take a five
foot eight guy if you really if it's
like no that's not your type though I
don't know why you're just not
describing it but there's always
variables isn't it like you said that
you would yeah but what what other
options do women have if they don't get
the guys they want they have to lower
their standards right not not by the
height and stuff this thing
but if only if only 15. if only 15 of
men are over six foot not everyone can
one guy over six foot and if he's
financially able to provide put that in
everything
oh gosh okay
um
you know some some people sign up for
that that's not my multiple wives some I
think do you know that's another thing
for me to get rid of women as well you
know
like when I told him that you know it
keeps me grounded right
hmm well having four wives that keeps
you grounded no telling them it doesn't
have foreign
[Music]
don't get too comfortable I'm probably
gonna have three more have you got have
you got a male friend that you could
call and ask for help
in what sense as in platonically yeah
platonically that you put in the
platonic Zone
but I put in the platonics on any well
he wants to come help me or I I need
help and I call him to help me yeah
but what's wrong with that oh
so I answer it first and I'll let you
I'll let you know I'll let you know
after
um
you've got a man to come and fix your
shelves you've got a man to come and fix
your bed you've got a man to come and
drop your little pee that you've got a
man that does the special treatment to
you when you're ready man for this
you've got a man for that you've got a
man for that obviously you don't
necessarily need a husband being a
modern woman do you
that's if I'm not married but obviously
if I am married or if I am in a
relationship you're going to give up
no I'm not going to give up why would I
ask my male friends if I have a a
partner that can do all those things he
might be away on work and and you need
to fix a shelf are you going to call and
pay somebody then I'll
I'll pay someone to do it then call your
friend that's platonic platonic friend
but what if they can't do it but what's
that got to do with you having four
wives yeah that's what I'm confused
about don't worry about my wives I'm
worried about you husbands because like
get me you know what you don't call them
husbands but they're husbands but you
would how is that but you're saying
they're busy right he can't fix the
Shelf I can do that myself but say I
don't know the dishwasher needs to be
okay I would call the dishwasher man to
fix it you're making it like an inherent
sexual thing like I have I have male
friends I have female friends you have
male friends if I have if I need a shelf
built maybe some of my female friends
who you know are in like who do like
that sort of trade like my male friends
they're not in that type of business I
have female friends who are so I would
be more more likely to what business are
they in like as in I have female friends
that do like like trade like um
Carpenter yeah like you you know female
Carpenters that's kind of cool yeah I
know a an a female plumber and like I
know so if you need your plumbing then
you're calling your female friend to do
it I'm calling my friend that has the
most ability to do that job not because
they're a man not because they're a
woman best you know what percent of
Carpenters and plumbers are women that's
I'm just shocked yeah no that's not like
two percent yeah but obviously I feel
like now especially with my generation
more women are getting into those sort
of Industries my next time older
Generations
I used to work I used to give
presentations yeah to plummet I used to
sell like Plumbing Tech stuff
when was the last time you asked a male
friend for help um
I used to look at like different classes
of plumbers coming in I'm telling you
they're they're not I wouldn't be with
them
I know it's a male-dominated industry
I'm not like I'm just shocked I'm just
shocked you know any because there's
very few so wait you guys me too are you
gonna ignore my chain of sorry you
didn't even ask her answer my question
when was the last time you had a male
friend with you asked the male friend to
help
well he's not really my friend he's my
Airbnb guest like no my logo not you her
the tonic logic
I'm not sure probably
don't know in the last in the last year
or so I don't know like if you don't
have to be like specific but what was it
for is it something that your female
friends couldn't do
what did I last ask my
yeah like probably I don't know like to
be honest I just see like I don't really
see it as a gendered thing I know I know
you don't but the guy that's coming to
your house no but it's not because he's
not coming tonight he's not coming all
right so a lot of women put guys in the
friend zone they're my friend they're my
he's my friend he's my friend but in his
eyes he's not necessarily your friend
he's he's a friend until I could get one
and I would say that is the truth for a
lot of like that is how a lot of men
feel but to say that that's how all men
feel and that there are no in the
history of the world there have been no
men and women that have been genuine
friends I think that's a ridiculous
statement to say like obviously a lot of
men do have that mentality where they'll
just like pretend to be your friend
until they see an opportunity where they
think they can like [__] you or whatever
do you have any friends like that that
are that is platonic 100 yeah call them
[Music]
[Laughter]
that would not know that I was here yeah
you have to make it believable though it
has to be like you have to
um like lead into it a little bit
so he has to like think it's real
you you know how you talk so you know
how you can make it real geez unread
yeah do you know what I mean like it's
up to you how many people are watching
at the moment he's platonic yeah
it's still pressure no but like for
example I have this one friend and what
if he says no who cares no but it's not
it's not that it's the fact that I know
he has like he has a girlfriend so he
like you know it's just a bit
disrespectful even to her but him me and
him single yeah no but I would I would
say I don't really necessarily right now
have friends that are single that I can
just call like that that odd my genuine
friends but if he was single I know I
could because him personally I've known
him so we went nursery together we grew
up together have pictures of us all
throughout the years and there's been
times where me and him are both been
singing I'm feeling horny and he's like
right I'll get a cab
I'll get the Uber so do you do you guys
genuinely think that you like you
personally do you guys think you can
never see a woman
for more than just a potential why why
do you why why are you separating your
vagina from you like I don't understand
I don't understand why like okay why is
it that if I want to have sex with you
that means that we can't be friends now
can you answer my question
no but is that a genuine friendship like
is that a genuine friendship then I mean
so what am I supposed to be chilling
with ugly fat girls it's not platonic so
would you not be friends with an ugly
fat buddy then isn't it I mean is their
personality do you maybe okay do you
agree with the statement that men will
[__] anything is that true or false
I would say that's falls for the most
part there are some men that are like
that but like in general
not not exceptions just the rule
uh
drunk 2 A.M they're super selective
they're not taking home a whale
um I'm not taking they're not they're
not dropping their standards a little
bit maybe they might drop their
standards but I don't think the majority
of men would take someone home do you
think you're beautiful me yeah I think
everyone's beautiful no do you think
you're beautiful I think I'm beautiful
you think you're mad pretty
I think I'm yeah so if you're mad pretty
me as a male friend am I supposed to not
want to have sex with you
you can if you were respectful then you
can have attraction towards someone
without wanting to have sex with them
wait so do you want to have sex with
every single person in the world you
find attractive
[Music]
that's where the attraction comes from
it's a sexual attraction a sexual
attraction just because it's a sexual
attraction it doesn't mean you have to
choose to put your penis inside yeah
yeah the point is the Friendship isn't
the same no no it's not a friendship no
even if you don't have sex it's not the
same Dynamic if one person wants to have
sex with you yeah I agree with that and
so you're not it's not you're it's not
the you're not genuinely free yeah but
then like yeah but then again just
because I think I'm as you put it mad
pretty that doesn't mean I think every
single guy wants to [__] me no no that's
not that's not what I'm saying yeah but
like just with her Point that's what I'm
saying I don't think because like I
think I'm pretty that doesn't mean every
guy I'm friends with you you think your
friends are not attracted to you they
don't find you track of it all
I think some of them yeah I would say
I'm not that type yeah
okay so I think I don't think I'm
everyone in the world's tired no what do
you think I only have sex with my type
what do you think men only has sex with
their type Boombastic I think some
people only had sex with people that
they find attractive if you have sex
with people that you don't find
attractive that's you but I don't think
that's all men it's all my type the ones
that I find attractive so it like my I
could I could find someone attractive
without them being my type
fair enough like if I if I like black
girls and I saw a beautiful white girl
but I'm not gonna have sex with her
because she's white hmm well um well but
it comes down to like having a genuine
friendship I would never have a
friendship for the sake of just having
someone there that's the female point
this is what I'm trying to get to that's
you no that's so that's such a sexist
comment how could you say that
yeah he's just telling you what it's
like to be a man
he's saying what he thinks it is to be a
man and he's projecting that onto all
men most men most men I've like
as I got older I recognized even when
somebody's like yeah it's a really sad
way you realize
because then you're like oh like all
these times I thought they genuinely
wanted to help me because my delusional
mind was like well I don't feel like
that about him so you know he not he's
never tried it I'm with me so but he's
just waiting for me to give him any
signs if you're an attraction with your
longest like male friend for
um I don't have male friends like that
because I don't believe men and women
the reason why I'm disagreeing with you
is because like I've had male co-stars
and obviously you become friends during
the whole filming process and it's been
so platonic so innocent and so pure on
your side yes
that's that's also business as well it's
a bit different no but if yeah if you're
working it's not that's not a friendship
constantly around but you build a
friendship on your co-stars there is
there is a bit of a Nuance here though
because I think I think like you can be
it depends what level of friendship
we're talking here because I'm friends
with a number of women and I don't find
them attractive I'm not trying to sleep
with them I'm not you know whatever but
I'm like what level of friendship are we
talking here it's not like I'm hanging
out with them every day they're more
people that I know maybe through through
work or I know them through some kind of
Social Circle or something like that
they're more acquaintances like like
super super like I don't actually have
really I don't think really any sort of
like super super close female friends
um you know I'm kind of friends with a
couple of x's a little bit you know we
chat on what's up a little bit that's
and then there's other women that I know
from different circumstances but I think
if you're talking about like super super
like close friends where you guys are
hanging out the whole time yeah
um
yeah I personally learned to sort of to
sort of limit that because of the
reasons that we've set because otherwise
it could be in this sort of slightly
dishonest situation yeah where if you
kind of like her and you're pretending
to be like super super friends but
really you just kind of you know waiting
so I'm somewhere in the middle with it I
think you can be acquaintances with it
certainly and you know but I think I
think that you could also cross a line
with it yeah and I think that has to be
very quickly uh and can clear boundaries
of like okay
I'm not going to completely ignore every
man that ever exists around me but at
the same time like you were saying I
wouldn't hang out with a guy and be
under a blanket and then say oh we're
platonic friends no I I just think that
women find it
you for you guys you could probably
switch on and switch off your sexual
energy or something like that it might
not necessarily be the same for men so
you'll be like oh I want to have a
boyfriend that I first met as friends
and we're friends and when we're friends
you don't want me to be sexually on you
you might to be just be platonic to you
and then when you're ready for me
because you think I'm good enough for
you to be um a boyfriend you want me to
switch on my attraction to you now as
opposed to the guy that you say is not
your friend but you call him to fix your
your bed and he comes and fix your bed
for no reward I've actually
um there was this woman who had to have
um testosterone replacement so she was
like it was only I don't know the
specifics in terms of the amount of
extra testosterone she was on but she
was like I was literally so horny and
the amount of testosterone men producing
a day was like something like 12 times
what she was having she was like it just
gave me an insight into how men are like
looking at women and then we're like
sexy or whatever you want and you're a
friend and then we're expecting them to
be because obviously our testosterone
levels are a lot lower and our
fluctuates theirs is like when we're
ovulating that's men every single
morning but 12 times it's a lot it's a
lot to yeah I think it's something like
nine times or something that the average
guy has the average woman so yeah and
that's every single day we only have it
throughout certain periods it obviously
fluctuates doesn't it for us bro you
could just see some legs and that's it
you didn't even try you didn't even aim
to see the legs she just came from
opposite you on the train and it's like
hypothetically you had a daughter
would you be concerned about her safety
all the time of course you are yeah I've
got a little sister concerned about
safety all the time
it's just it's I think it's just natural
that if you've got as soon as you've got
a child especially for men as well
they're like nope but that's why you
should be going to your dad with your
your choices of who you want to be with
and stuff and guys you want to be around
that that's a good choice because he
doesn't like um
he has nothing really to gain from you
sexually so he's just gonna be like
listen I'm gonna tell you how it is yeah
not sugar coat it necessarily
I would hope not like I think that's
just
no because they could sugar coat it for
you and be like but no like that's
that's not the right type of guy but
because they're protecting that's
protection protections they're not going
to allow you to go into that space of
making Reckless decisions with your body
because they understand how you will
devalue yourself listen no no daughter
of mine is going to come to me and say
Dad this is my male friend we're just
going to go upstairs and chat wasn't
that right
how many male friends is it a red flag
it's like how many male friends does a
girl have to have that it's a red flag
to you
like listen if she's like this is the
common thing if I hear I'll really get
along with girls red flag if I hear like
if it's like a guy is ringing you all
the time and you're like oh you're just
a friend that's that's a problem for me
as well
so it could be one it could be a
thousand just depends how they are yeah
but you just said like guys can't handle
themselves right like the women
attractive woman the woman is the one
that handles the man so she's like yeah
a man could be unto you a thousand times
but if she says no a thousand times
that's loyal girl that's a loyal girl
did you get it if she says once a lot of
women don't want to have to play defense
I think I think I think what you said is
right though if she's like oh I don't
really get on me girls you know I just
get all my guys much better that's a bit
yes like yeah that's something you lay
in the field the the the the um you're
laying the little dots on the field for
me to be accepting of you to have a lot
of a lot of male friends listen
I don't want to come with the excuse of
oh it was an accident and we shouldn't
have been there we shouldn't have been
doing this oh I was drunk it was a
feeling and he dropped onto me by
accident well if he was in that
situation it wouldn't have been like
that and you told me about male friends
how much times have male friends been
the reason why girls break up
yeah and they'll be in their ears saying
oh he's not treating you yeah I wouldn't
treat you like that
I don't do that your boyfriend sounds
like a dick
it's like he is that's why she's with
him
hero hey I'm not what about you beard
gang male friends
uh no I mean there's no reason for my
girl to have male friends do I mean if
she needs anything she could come to me
so yeah but if you're not there yeah
what if you're you're talking to her
what do you mean like going on a date
you're not officially boyfriend and
girlfriend
who am I to say then okay so if there's
no amount that's a red flag
if she's just always with other guys all
the time then yeah it's a red flag of
course
what about you guys female friends
mix mix I'm a bit different and yeah
that doesn't matter so much because if
he's going to cheat it's his choice
isn't he's going to cheat whereas it's
yeah I think it's a bit different for
men to have female friends than it is
for for me I think it says a lot about a
man as well because I don't necessarily
want to be in a relationship with a man
who genuinely believes that men and
women can't be friends because yeah all
men and women can't be friends it's all
down to context aren't it like if you've
got if you've got a friend that you've
been friends with all your life is
completely different yeah about what I'm
saying but if it's like we're together
and you've just got a new friend yeah
like why are you making new friends
that guy's not your friend trust me if
you're working with people who are the
opposite sex you you can't they call it
that's colleagues build uh friendships
depending on your job you might yeah but
colleagues regardless you speak work
husbands here I mean what do you never
heard work husband yeah but you don't
obviously there's a level of trust that
you have to have for your partner I
wouldn't be with someone who I think or
who I thought would actually all right
all right so check this check this
you're in a relationship yeah are you
going for after work drinks with some
guy from work just you two alone
that I think there are some women who no
who it seems you get the sense of
slightly more open to that than others
like for example what what are my
ex-girlfriends right she had some male
friends but these were guys that she'd
know literally for since she was a kid
like for years and I I met them and I
hung out with them and they were all you
know it's it as far as I know it's all
cool it seemed all absolutely fine to me
but there was another girl that I was
with before and she was a bit more like
you know she was she was you know
meeting guys at work but it was all like
after work drinks and you know and it
like and it just seemed like this girl's
just like open to this kind of stuff do
you know what I mean so obviously with
with her I didn't I didn't trust her and
that came to them very quickly the other
guy though it was different because
because like I said it's about context I
think yeah it's situation so if you
would you go to the drinks after work
but the drinks after the drinks after
work leads into the other stuff that so
you know we've discussed already which
is like because
the whole culture now is much more about
that isn't it the whole culture is much
more about like instant gratification
you know and um and if you said to
somebody I don't want you to go out for
drinks after work that would be seen as
that could be seen as coercive
sorry can I ask you something then yeah
so see all right wait so say for example
yeah
you said colleagues turn to friends all
right that's cool calm so if I had if we
were going out together yeah and I've
had a colleague at work she's really
pretty and we we came we became friends
and we had a work trip that we had to go
away for well in Aspen we have to go
away for work trip is that all right I'm
coming with you baby
well I mean depends what the dough looks
like I wouldn't I wouldn't get married
to someone that I think would cheat on
me regardless so I would be trusted like
what are you just gonna ban your partner
from going on all work trips because
they it's not just men they work all
right so if if if you check the girl's
Instagram and she could see that she was
much prettier than you would you feel
free I wouldn't be insecure to the point
where I would check Instagram so I would
be checking check and checking like okay
but you just saw it you just came across
your Instagram and you're like this is
the girl that is going away with on this
trip maybe you dropped him off lunch at
work and you just saw this girls
who who's your do you have like a
celebrity girl that you like think is
really pretty
tonight
she looks like Megan good it's my
colleague man
what if you knew that most of most of
the girls in the office
on a balance of probabilities would
sleep with him if given the chance
would it change it at all no because
like you have to have trust for your
partner if I know or I believe that
they're not going to you wouldn't say
anything you'd be cool calm and
collected not not a word you'll be at
home and stressing though you let him go
but you'll be at home stressing
I don't know like maybe but at the end
of the day like to the point in being in
a relationship with someone if you don't
trust them like you miss your interest
but there's always going to be like our
little mind like security is no it likes
to create stories our minds are creating
stories all the time until you have
confirmation there's there's always a or
something might happen you might call
him and he doesn't answer then all of a
sudden you've got creating a story in
your mouth says another girl's name and
then you create in a story in our
minds yeah so there's a difference
and then saying oh yeah you're not
allowed to speak to this person
like those are the two yeah of course
but he was saying over there that would
you be worried and you were like no I
wouldn't even think about it that's not
what he said he said would you check
your Instagram and I said no no no no my
question for me oh you said you wouldn't
be worried
if I went away if I was in a
necessarily be
worried that he's going to cheat I might
like be
um like have slight insecurities within
me thinking maybe maybe but like I
wouldn't think that he actually would it
would just be thoughts in the back and
passing thoughts but it's not like I
would never think that my life partner
would do that have you ever been cheated
on before
um when I was younger like young yeah
and you were never jealous in that
situation
before that happened I didn't think you
would do that to me no no when I found
out this is this is how to catch the cap
you told your friends that story what do
you think they would tell you
I think they would say yeah like
obviously I was cheated on when I was
like 15 years old like I'm a little kid
I'm saying if you told your friends that
my boyfriend has gone on a work trip
with with his platonic friend and this
is what she looks like she looks like
Megan good what do you think your
friends are gonna say to you
like what my friends would think I would
say or what my oh what my friends are
gonna say to me in that situation yes I
think in that situation some of my
friends who are more jealous are more
possessive might give me advice that oh
yeah he's gonna do this is that but I'm
not gonna let what my friends say impact
my relationship because me and mine no
my our relationship better than anyone I
just want to say
that I would absolutely be jealous
yeah I would be very jealous yeah
I was been going any work trips I can't
not let him go okay but then that's why
like I can't you have to if you want
communicate how you feel if if I would
try my best not to but I'm still I'm
still human
if a girl that looks like Megan Good was
and I knew she kind of liked him was I'd
be like you're gonna take a plus one
sweetie we can make a whole holiday out
of it honestly if I knew she kind of
like I would just assume they hooked up
I would just assume I'm taking this out
his right mind is gonna turn that down
so he's staying with you so I mean like
they're they're you're telling me
they're in a hotel with all their
co-workers where they're getting drinks
and this is a beautiful woman that's
into him and he's just gonna be like oh
no not today okay now we're just
watching movies I'd like I'd be sitting
at home trying to stay sane
maybe like lying to myself
um okay I'm gonna close out the show
because it's actually getting really
late
uh final thoughts any social media you
want to plug I'm starting here and then
go around
um the final thoughts thanks for having
us on it's been an interesting
conversation
um yeah uh my Instagram is Christine
Grace Smith
um I don't have any final thoughts I'm
sure everybody's sick of my thoughts um
and my Instagram is n underscore
alexander87 and my YouTube's I know me
Naomi and yeah that's it thanks for
having me again
I generally am very curious to what did
you say call my bluff or something like
that call the bluff yeah yeah come back
you definitely need a follow-up yeah
make sure you know how I'm just gonna go
psychic
um
so it's basically nadashi Hopkins
n-a-d-e-s-h-i Hopkins as in Anthony
Hopkins for Instagram Tick Tock YouTube
yeah that's pretty much it
um my Instagram is s-h-e-y-a-n-n-e-e-e-e
um and my Tick Tock is got that mac and
cheese wrap but I don't make thirst
traps I don't get excited I just speak
on
this type of [__] basically
I love mac and cheese
my friends don't want some of that yo
listen yeah um final thoughts um do you
know what today I actually like the
balance of the people down here I think
everyone had a nice something something
to add to the to the Pod you know I'm
saying you know I always enjoy coming to
the just party things
um podcast and that you know I mean also
subscribe to my channel if you've got
time it's it's the fresh prince of
Mundo you got me
just don't go there for any science
for Life advice
man you get me ignore these but yeah
peace thank you so much for having me
guys you know what I'm saying tell them
to two videos you reacted to this week
your two favorites
um two favorite videos I reacted to
ah a couple swap phones for a couple
minutes I like that that was a that was
a that was a nice spicy one and um
it's not I'm not the father
it was another good one
yeah
that's two favorites
nice
[Music]
final thoughts uh varieties the spice of
life guys
don't get tied down you know there's a
lot of different flavors out there
um or if you do think very seriously
about it and stick to your vows uh
follow me at real Troy Francis on
YouTube on Instagram uh Twitter and Tick
Tock as well for all your dating
coaching dating advice needs and uh yeah
it's been a great show thanks very much
final thoughts uh protect your money and
get your bid right so
um
you get me there you go DMV Instagram
for Taylor advice beard gang members
yeah it's sorry is that actually you've
got a whole
[Music]
the final piece of advice as well should
be all guys watching this sign off all
your assets to your mum immediately yeah
as long as you trust her or set up a
shell company in the Cayman Islands
either way keep it offshore
um a couple I'm gonna read the last
Super chats
um girl in all black you're hot I'm from
America New York City to be exact I wish
Pearl wasn't closing the chat so soon I
just got on about 10 minutes ago wow
that's other social media
can't Co I'm representing the Sims
simping for the blonde
smolder
what's your final thoughts my final
thoughts is that I would absolutely be
jealous
my other final thought is that
let's see what this guy says
yeah I'm excited to hear back I better
you better DM me all right I will yeah I
will I need updates
um I'd love for you to come to call your
male friend I bet they would sleep with
you based
um yeah that's it hey wait one thing I
would say though you see you see that if
you call him and tell him that yeah
things happen really quickly with those
with those Muslim couples you know
you'll be on a plane in two minutes
before you can even say it's a fix yeah
you already you know what he's he's I
would actually be the funniest outcome
if he actually says yeah
if it works out I would like something a
wedding a wedding could come out of this
yeah
um okay guys a couple announcements
before we end the show
um subscribe to our two clips channels
just probably clips and pro daily guys
snico and Jay Waller are coming next
week so Monday and Tuesday we're gonna
have shows I don't usually do them
Mondays and Tuesdays but uh same time
um as when did we start today like nine
yeah nine eight thirty nine roughly
um
oh you got another Super Chat again girl
in the all black you're hot shout out to
blessing Pearl you're still number one
thank you thank you for that maybe I'll
maybe I won't have a cat after all
guys sign up for the fourth membership
tier and guys sign up for the Google
form um we're gonna do meetups in London
and we're also gonna do meetups when we
go back to the US
um we we had a fun one a couple weeks
ago so we're probably gonna do another
um the whole staff there it'll be fun
um also
uh subscribe to wife school I think
that's pretty much it like the video on
your way out guys subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
I agree with you I think they do do it
for the men but it's like sexual tension
it's not really relationship attention
so you can kind of do a cheat code you
can go get a BBL get a nice body and you
do get more attention from them than if
you're flat right but here's the thing
though no no but but listen though if it
goes so deeper though because I know who
you're talking about and she has a great
body yeah so you got to think about how
far down deep that she is within
watching the Instagram models within
watching The Cosmopolitan magazines
great body doesn't look good to a man
but you think that men have higher
standards for women not that the men
have the higher standards they have to
live up to just to clarify I think men
have highest under School women for
women so like the women have higher
beauty standards to me yes and that's
what's making women feel like they need
to comply with these standards who's
pickier men or women men and women are
more complacent than them
are more complacent yeah I think they
accept all them and do you think men are
very like if they're they've got a
certain standard and they're more rigid
than women I think men are pickier than
women 100 definitely but they will not
marry they will not settle down with
somebody with a fake or lips the
eyebrows and if they do it ain't gonna
last
boobs lingerie yeah yeah builds right
whatever
when I finished it I felt very degraded
I felt very like why did I actually do
that now I know there's girls out there
who do that they don't feel that way
that is perfectly fine you do you you
feel the way you feel but me personally
like like in the future how like when I
have kids and all in the future and if
my kids found out about that they'll
probably get bullied in school there are
people like oh your mom doing this your
mom doing that and your man as well he's
not going to if you don't respect
yourself and you're selling your body
online I can't speak for everyone I can
just speak for myself if you're selling
your body online like that there's not
there's not a high respect for yourself
foreign